[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, please welcome
Senior Vice President,
Vic Gundotra.
VIC GUNDOTRA: Well, good
morning and hello.
And on behalf of Google, let me
extend our warmest welcome
to the 6,000 of you here in
attendance as well as the over
40,000 who have joined us in 440
viewing parties across 90
countries worldwide.
And to the over one million
who are watching live on
YouTube right now, welcome to
the sixth annual Google I/O.
Our platform and services teams
have worked incredibly
hard to get to this point.
And I hope you're going to be
delighted by some of the
surprises we have in store
for you this morning.
But as that opening
video showed, it's
really not about us.
It's about you, developers,
who are building the most
amazing and magical experiences
that make those
platforms and services
come alive.
So when we say thank you, we
really sincerely mean it.
Your support, your enthusiasm,
your building of apps for our
platform and services has
been deeply appreciated.
And we hope that the things
that you'll see at this
conference will continue to
inspire you and that we at
Google will continue
to earn your trust.
So with that, let's get
this keynote started.
Please join me in welcoming
my friend Sundar Pichai.
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Thank you, Vic.
It's incredibly exciting
to be here.
Welcome to Google I/O. I think
we are in the middle of one of
the most pivotal moments
in personal computing.
We are going through one of the
most innovative phases in
personal computing.
Most of you in this audience
have lived through the PC
revolution.
An incredibly important
revolution in our lifetime.
It started around 1980.
But if you take a look back, for
over 25 years most people
in the world used one operating
system, which was Windows.
And in terms of hardware form
factors, it evolved from
desktops to laptops over
a long period of time.
But fast forward to about
seven years ago.
With the advent of smartphone,
there's been an explosion of
devices, phones and tablets and
increasingly newer types
of devices.
People are adopting these
devices at an amazing pace
because it has a profound
impact on
their day to day lives.
Nothing captures this moment
as the picture behind me.
These are two pictures in
the same location in
Saint Peter's Basilica.
The one on the left is a the
funeral of Pope John Paul II.
The one on the right is the
announcement of the new Pope
Francis recently.
For sure, different moments,
the one on the
left this more somber.
But you can see there is one
person way ahead of their time
with a clam shell phone trying
to take a picture.
But you look at the one on the
right, a sea of phones
capturing that moment.
The world has changed pretty
dramatically just in a span of
six to seven years.
Increasingly people are using
many, many different types of
computing devices.
It's not just desktops, phones,
and laptops anymore.
It's watch with displays.
Its thermostats with displays.
Maybe a car console has a
display and maybe something
like Google Glass.
When you look at all these
computing devices, it's a
multi-screen world.
These are all small displays
with a lot of
computing power in them.
In addition to that,
they have sensors.
They can listen.
They can feel.
They can hear.
And the amount of computing
power in these screens is
incredible.
And users are really adopting
these computing devices.
We at Google are incredibly
excited.
This is why we view this as
one of the most important
moments in computing.
And we're working very,
very hard to continue
this journey forward.
The reason is at the heart of
this journey is the impact we
can have on people
around the world.
That's what this journey
of personal computing
is about for us.
We are very, very fortunate at
Google to have two platforms,
two large open platforms, two
fast growing platforms, two
scalable platforms completely
designed for developers like
you to build amazing
experiences, Android and Chrome.
Android started with a simple
goal of bringing open
standards to the mobile
industry.
Today it is the most popular
mobile operating
system in the world.
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Chrome, again,
started as a simple journey to
make the web much better, both
as a platform for developers
and as an experience
for users.
The goal was to design
a simpler,
safer, and faster browser.
And today it is the
most popular
browser used in the world.
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Android and
Chrome, as I said earlier, are
really designed for people
to build amazing
experiences on top.
We at Google are working hard
on top of these platforms.
We call this the
best of Google.
We are building products like
search, Maps, YouTube, Google
Now, and many more new things
which you will hear about
later today.
So we are working hard on top of
these platforms to push the
journey of computing forward.
But what really excites is that
developers like you can
build thousands of third party
applications, great
applications which really make a
difference on top of Android
and Chrome.
And that's what a lot of
this keynote is about.
What are we doing on top of
these platforms so that you
can continue doing the
great work you do?
With that, let's get started.
We're going to talk
about Android.
So two years ago we announced
we had over 100 million
activations of Android.
We were incredibly excited at
the rate of the of growth.
And a year ago at Moscone we
celebrated the fact that we
have four 400 million
activations of Android.
The momentum has been
breathtaking since then.
So let's take a look
at where we are.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: 900 million.
It's an extraordinary
achievement.
But it's an extraordinary
ecosystem achievement.
We couldn't have gotten there
without the help of a lot of
you in the audience and people
around the world, developers
around the world.
We are incredibly humbled by
where we have reached.
But we have to remember there
are over 7 billion people on
this planet.
So we have a long way to go.
And we think the journey is
just getting started.
So if you look, we're going
to put a map of the world.
And we're going to highlight
for you areas of the world
where the penetration of Android
is less than 10%.
And as you can see, while we're
growing very, very fast,
most of the world, the countries
in green here
represent over four and
a half billion people.
And the penetration of Android
is less than 10%.
But it is growing
very, very fast.
So a lot of this journey is
about bringing that next four
and a half billion people online
and making a difference
in their lives.
So we're going to talk a lot
about what we are doing in
Android both for developers
and users to
continue this momentum.
And to get started, I'm going to
invite Hugo onto the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Good morning,
everyone.
Thank you, Sundar.
How are you guys doing
this morning?
[CHEERING]
HUGO BARRA: Great.
You guys just heard about the
spectacular Android ecosystem
momentum all around the world.
Well it's also been an amazing
year for Android developers.
Here's a pretty insane
number for you.
Google Play has just crossed
48 billion app installs.
That's right.
That's a huge number.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
HUGO BARRA: And two and a half
billion installs in the last
month alone.
But even better than that, over
the last four months,
this year, we've already paid
out more money to Android
developer's on Google Play
than in all of last year.
And revenue per user--
thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: And revenue per
user, which is a pretty
important stat for all of us, is
two and half times what it
was just a year ago globally.
So you guys, Android developers,
are really the
heart of this ecosystem.
And I think that
you know that.
We've been in this incredible
journey together for over five
years now since the first
Android SDK came out.
And as Vic said, Google
I/O is all about you.
And we're here to show
that we're listening.
And we're here because we really
want you to thrive.
So let's go.
Let's get started here.
The first thing we want to do is
give you a preview of some
exciting developer tools and
services that we're announcing
here at I/O. And, of course,
you'll get to see these in
great detail in the 52 Android
sessions and code labs that
we've put together just for you
over the next three days.
All right, so first off is
Google Play services.
A few months ago we launched
Google Play services as a
layer built and managed
by Google on top
on the Android platform.
It includes API that we at
Google use to build our own
apps like Google Maps
and Google Now.
And we're making these APIs
available to you so that you
can make your apps
even better.
Google Play services
are distributed
via the Play Store.
And it's automatically updated
directly by Google
independently of operating
system versions.
This means you have access to
the latest APIs consistently
on all devices.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
Now, one of the first API's that
we launched as part of
Google Play services was the
Google Maps Android API v2.
Many of you already use
it in your apps.
You're looking here at
the Expedia app.
And you can see this is a major
user experience upgrade
compared to the original Android
platform Maps API.
It allows you to build Google
Maps directly into your app,
amazing vector based maps, full
3D movement and rotation,
and 3D building profiles.
Looks really, really great.
Now, location is a key input
to so many apps.
The Google Maps API is, of
course, a huge part of this.
But today we're going to take
it one step further by
launching three new
location APIs as
part of Google services.
A first API is called Fused
Location Provider.
We've completely rewritten our
locations algorithms, taking
advantage of all the sensors so
that location is now faster
to acquire.
It's more accurate.
And we're also adding a new low
power location mode that
uses less than 1% of
battery per hour.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: The second new
location API that we're
announcing today
is Geofencing.
Geofencing lets you define
virtual fences around
geographic areas.
And those trigger when
the user enters
or exits these areas.
You can have up to 100 geofences
simultaneously
active per app.
This has been a big
ask from you guys.
There you go.
That's what I thought.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: So I thought
you would like that.
The third new location API that
we're announcing today is
Activity Recognition.
There's been a lot of interest
from the developer community
for apps that help users track
their physical activities.
This new API, Activity
Recognition, uses
accelerometer data and machine
learning classifiers to
automatically figure out when
the user is walking, cycling,
or driving.
And we do it in a really battery
efficient way without
even turning on the GPS.
So we think there's going to
be a whole new category of
awesome apps that take
advantage of this new
capability.
So let's keep going.
Another Google Play services API
that we launched a couple
months ago was Google+
Sign-in.
And as many of you know, that
lets people sign into your app
with their existing Google
credentials so that you don't
have to create a new account
name space and users don't
have to remember yet
another passport.
Today we're expanding that
capability by introducing
cross platform single sign-on.
It's really exciting.
And I want to show you
that right now.
So Jai is here in The
Fancy Web site.
He's on his computer.
He has not created
a Fancy account.
But he is signed into Google.
And when he tries to fancy,
let's say, this margarita
maker, he's prompted to
create an account.
He's going to choose Google+
as his Sign-in method here.
Now here's the interesting
part.
He's getting an option to
automatically install the
fancy app on his
Android tablet.
That's pretty cool because now
he doesn't have to remember to
go find it and install
it later.
It just does it all for him.
So he's fancied his mixed
drink machine here.
Now let's switch over to his
tablet and take a look.
Now, Jai should have gotten
the notification--
there it is--
that says the app was
automatically
installed on his tablet.
This actually just happened.
And we--
thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: And when he opens
the app here, because he's
already signed in on The Fancy
Web site, he's automatically
logged into the Fancy on
his Android tablet.
Isn't that cool?
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: So he goes to the
My Collection section, which
shows things that he's fancied
before, there it is.
That's your margarita
machine, Jai.
That's pretty cool.
So that's cross-platform single
sign-on in action.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: So let's keep going
with Google Play services.
Last year at I/O we announced
Google Cloud
Messaging, or GCM for short.
GCM is a service that's managed
by Google that lets
you seamlessly push data
from your servers to
your Android apps.
GCM was super well
received by the
entire developer community.
60% of the top 100 apps
in Play Store
today are using GCM.
We're delivering 200,000 GCM
push messages every second.
That's 17 billion
messages a day.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
And what's even more impressive
is the average
server to server latency.
That's 60 milliseconds, which
is actually 30% faster than
when we launched this service
just a year ago.
So the news here today is
that GCM is now part
of Google Play services.
And we're announcing three major
new features as part of
a major upgrade.
So, first, GCM now supports
persistent connections between
your servers and Google.
With a persistent connection you
can send a large number of
messages to many, many
devices very quickly.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Second, we're
launching one of the GCM
features that you have
requested the most.
And I think you'll like this.
Upstream messaging,
there you go.
You can now use GCM to send data
in the other direction as
well, so from your app to your
servers just as seamlessly.
GCM, of course, does all the
client side connection
[INAUDIBLE] before you.
It automatically retries
if the network
isn't up and so on.
So it really helps to keep
battery and data usage as
minimal as possible.
Third, and I'm sure you'll
love this one too, we're
launching another GCM API that
synchronizes notifications for
you so that when you dismiss a
notification on one device--
there you go.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: So that same
notification goes away on the
other device as well.
And you'll see more about
this here today.
All of the three new major GCM
features you saw are rolling
out progressively.
And all you have to
do is sign up.
And you can do that
starting today.
So to summarize, this is
where we are right now.
These are the Google Play
services we've covered
already, the Maps API, the new
location APIs, Google+ sign-in
with cross-platform single
sign-on, and GCM with upstream
messaging and synchronized
notifications.
Now we're going to cover one
more service, a major one that
we're adding today.
So let's talk about gaming.
Everybody loves gaming.
And with the explosion of
tablets all around the world,
games are doing better
than ever.
And today we're announcing a
new family of APIs built
specifically for game
developers.
We call it Google Play
game services.
So let's talk about that.
The first new Google Play game
services API is Cloud Save.
Cloud Save enables you to save
user data across devices like
player progression
and game state.
So if a player finishes playing
level one on his
phone, for example, he can then
pick up is Android tablet
and start playing right
away from level two.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Next, are APIs for
achievements and leader boards.
Achievements are virtual trophy
walls that make it
really easy for you to increase
engagement inside
your games.
And leader boards use Google+
Circles to connect players and
really encourage friendly
competition.
Let's put it that way.
So here we are in the game
called the World of Goo.
And from within the game my
friend Jai can launch into a
leader board and see how he
ranks against other players.
So here in the public leader
boards you can see that he's
actually not very
highly ranked.
You can't even find him.
That's the public
leader board.
But that's OK because he's
number two amongst his friends
on Google+, which looks pretty
cool until, of course, you see
who's number one.
Now, Cloud Save, achievements,
and leader boards are APIs
that we're launching not only
on Android, but also for iOS
and web so you can have cross
platform gaming experiences,
which I think is pretty
important.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Now here's where
it gets really exciting.
The next Google Play game
services API that we're
announcing today is a
comprehensive multiplayer
service for matching players and
engaging them in head to
head competition.
We know, obviously, because you
tell us, that building low
latency, real time synchronous
games is pretty damn hard.
So we want to help.
So the first thing we'll do is
we're going to deal with all
the hard networking problems and
manage all of the device
peer-to-peer connections
for you.
And then the second thing we'll
do via Google+ is make
it easier for your players to
invite friends that they want
to play with or against, as
well as quickly find new
people that they
can challenge.
What you'll see here are some
of the developers that we've
been working on to integrate
Google Play games services
into their titles.
There's actually lots of games
launching today with many of
these capabilities that
we talked about.
Now, these game APIs that we
just talked about are also
part of Google Play services,
by the way.
And all the core APIs that you
see here, some of the things
that we talked about today,
will be available via an
update to Google Play services
that we're rolling out today
to all Android devices,
Froyo and up.
And we'll continue to add the
best of Google innovation so
that you can continue to
build awesome apps.
Now--
thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: I want to
shift gears and talk
about developer tools.
One of the most common pieces
of feedback that we get from
you all the time is that you
want more options for Android
development.
Well, today we want to show you
a new Android tool that
we've been working on.
It's called Android Studio and
it's based on the community
edition of IntelliJ
from JetBrains--
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: --which,
obviously, you
guys know very well.
Android Studio is an IDE that's
truly built for Android
with the goal of making you
faster and much more
productive as an
app developer.
Now, I'd like to show
you this live.
And to do that, here's Tor
Norbye from the Android Tools
team for a quick demo.
Take it away.
TOR NORBYE: Good Morning.
Today, I want to share with
you a few of my favorite
features in Android Studio.
As Hugo said, Android studio is
based on IntelliJ, so it's
a fully featured IDE right
from the get-go.
What I love about it is the
attention to detail, which
makes it a pleasure to use.
The IDE has a deep semantic
model of your code and it
understands Android.
So that makes the Code Editor
smarter and more productive.
Take, for example, this
code right here.
This is how your write
internationalised apps in Android.
You don't hard code
your strings.
You look them up from
resource files.
Well, this IDE can figure out
what the real strings are and
show them to you in place in the
editor as if you had hard
coded the string.
[APPLAUSE]
TOR NORBYE: So note that the
code is still there.
It's just easier to read.
And we don't just
preview strings.
On the next few lines
you can see that I'm
manipulating some icons.
And those icons are previewed
right here
in the editor margin.
[APPLAUSE]
TOR NORBYE: And so, likewise,
here's a color file.
And you can see that we resolve
the colors and preview
those in editor margin
as well.
Now, when you're editing your
layouts, you now get a live
rendering of what the layout
is going to look like at
runtime time.
And what makes this really
powerful is that we have
multi-configuration editing.
So what if I want to know what
this layout looks like on
different screen sizes?
Let's take a look.
So here it is.
[APPLAUSE]
TOR NORBYE: So here, I can see
my current layout rendered on
a 3.7 inch phone, 10
inch tablet, and
everything in between.
It's also showing me that I have
a custom tablet layout to
take advantage of that
extra space.
This feature is also great
for internationalization.
So if we jump into the settings
layout for our app, I
can now take a look at the
languages we're targeting.
And so, here, I can see my
layouts with the different
message catalogs applied.
So I can see Norwegian
in the bottom
left corner, for example.
[APPLAUSE]
TOR NORBYE: So let's say
I want to make an edit.
Let's say I want to bump up the
font size on this second
label here.
I can do that.
And that's obviously too big.
So let me go back a little
and make it 26.
So now this looks
OK in English.
But notice that in German right
next to it right over
here, this string is actually
wrapping, which I don't want.
So at this point I could either
continue tweaking my
layout or get a shorter
translation if that's possible.
So, in short, this is a feature
that makes it really
easy to ensure that your layouts
work well across a
variety of devices and
configurations.
And while I focused on the Code
Editor today, this also
works in the full UI builder.
We have big plans for
Android Studio.
We plan to integrate more and
more services into the IDE.
For example, with the simple
menu item, I can add a Google
Cloud Messaging back
end into my app.
And then I can take advantage
of all those great GCM APIs
that Hugo told you
about earlier.
And this is just scratching
the surface of all the new
features in Android Studio.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: All right.
I think I actually lost
my prompter, guys.
I need somebody to advance
that mainly for me, if we
could do that.
The prompter, please?
OK, well, then we
can ad lib it.
And so, of course, half of the
game is about building awesome
apps, developer tools, and
services, and so on.
The other half is about
distribution and monetization.
How do you find more users?
How do you monetize your app?
To tell you about a bunch of
new features to the Android
developer console, I'd like to
invite on stage Ellie Powers
from the Android product team.
Ellie, come on up.
ELLIE POWERS: All right.
Hi, everybody.
I'm Ellie and this is Miles.
So last year at Google I/O we
announced the new Google Play
developer console.
And since then you've sent us
tons of feedback telling us
exactly what you want
to see next.
We've taken that feedback into
account and today I'm here to
tell you about five new features
that we're adding to
the developer console to help
you get more users and make
more money on Android.
So let's get started.
The first feature I want
to tell you about is
optimization tips.
So let's take a look here.
We can see all of my apps in
the developer console.
And let's take a look at Fortune
Teller, which is my
most popular app.
OK, here we go.
This app is doing pretty well.
But I'm always wondering what
can I do to make Fortune
Teller a bit more successful?
And that's exactly what
we had in mind with
optimization tips.
It analyzes your app.
We look at how your app is
doing in the Play Store.
And we offer you insights about
how you can improve it.
So what do we have today?
We have two optimization tips.
The first one is telling us that
we should design our app
for tablets by uploading
tablet screenshots.
Now, this is really important,
and I should definitely do it
because it will encourage
more users on tablets
to install my app.
Next, it's telling me that I
have a lot of users who speak
Russian, and they're already
using my app.
But my app isn't actually
translated into Russian.
So that's another opportunity
for me.
OK, I don't speak Russian, so
I need to get some help.
It used to be a lot
of work to find a
translator for your apps.
You had to search the internet
looking for a good company.
But we want to make
this easier.
So that's why today we're now
going to use our new app
translation service,
fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: And we're
announcing this today.
This service allows you to get
professional translations
directly in the developer
console.
And we're going to try it out.
OK, it takes just a minute to
upload the strings we want
translated into the Google Play
developer console here.
Next, we select the languages
that we want
to translate into.
So for today, we're, of course,
going to select
Russian and try to help
those guys out.
Next, it's going to show us a
list of all the different
translation vendors.
And then I can just pick one
that suits my budget.
And that's it.
Google will send my
strings off to
the translation company.
And then in about a week they
come back and I can download
them directly from the
developer console.
Super simple.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: Some of you may be
interested in participating
in this pilot program.
So please sign up in the
developer console today.
OK, now I've gotten Fortune
Teller ready
for the Russian market.
So I want to invest in a
campaign to promote my app.
But naturally I want
to know which ads
are the most effective.
And that's why we're announcing
referral tracking.
This makes it easy to
understand which
ads are most effective.
And we're going to switch to
Google Analytics to take a
look at it.
OK, here we're adding
a new report in
the acquisition section.
This is a conversion
funnel report with
data from Google Play.
It shows us where our installs
come from, like blogs or top
websites and other
important ads.
So here we go.
This will allow us to track
the effectiveness of each
referral channel.
So in the left we have each of
the channels followed by how
many users view, install,
and launch our app.
OK, installations with
an app are really
just the first step.
What you want is for users
to come back to your
app again and again.
And I want to understand how
often people are using my app.
I can do that with
Google Analytics.
But I have to go to
So soon we're going to be
showing these great engagement
metrics from Google Analytics
directly in
the developer console.
You'll have all your metrics--
thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: We want to give
you all your metrics together
in the same place.
These two analytics features
are rolling
out later this summer.
So now we have an app
that people are
launching all the time.
So, of course, it's time
to make money.
Like you, I just want to have
simple tools to show me how
much money I'm making
every single day.
So now we've added a new tab
to the developer console
giving us a summary of
our app's revenue.
You can see your global
revenue and how
it varies over time.
And then we can even show
country specific revenue.
For example, we can check how
our app's doing in Japan.
Wow, it looks like we had
a great day last week.
It must have been our
new in app products.
Fantastic.
So that's it.
Revenue is at your fingertips
just like the
rest of your metrics.
OK.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE].
ELLIE POWERS: All right, so
we have a successful app.
We're making lots of money.
So now I'm ready to try some
new features with my app.
Now it's important.
I really want to find out what
do my core users think about
these new features before I roll
them out to everybody?
And from your feedback,
I think a lot of you
want to do this too.
So today we are launching
beta testing.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah, a lot of
you talk to me on Google+
about this one and also
staged roll outs.
Let's take a look.
OK, we now have three tabs in
the developer console, alpha
testing, beta testing,
and production.
We want to start with a small--
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: All right,
thank you.
We'll start with a small group
of alpha testers and then roll
out to a larger group
of beta testers.
Let's set it up.
OK, we select the APK
for our test.
Next, we're going to use Google
Groups and Google+
Communities to control
access to the app.
Keep in mind here feedback will
be sent directly to me.
And it's not posted
as public reviews.
That's very important.
OK, so now we have
our new version.
We're ready to put it
into production.
But rather than upgrading all my
users in one go, I can now
manage the roll out.
So we can select a percentage
here, like, let's say, 10%.
and then we'd increase it over
time when we're ready.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: Don't applaud
at the same time.
Let's start with 10%
on this side.
OK, so that was our five
new features in
the developer console.
We had optimization tips, the
app translation service, usage
metrics with referral tracking,
revenue graphs, and
beta testing with staged
roll outs.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: All right,
thank you.
HUGO BARRA: Thanks, Ellie.
So just checking, how's
everyone doing?
How are you guys feeling?
Pretty good?
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: OK.
Well, I don't know about you,
but I'm feeling pretty API'd
out at the moment.
So I guess it's probably a
good time to move on to
something maybe a little
bit more playful.
With that, I want to introduce
a man whose name is always
music to my ears.
Ladies and gentlemen,
our resident
rock star, Chris Yerga.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: Thank you, Hugo.
Good morning, everyone.
[JAPANESE], Tokyo.
Thanks for staying up.
All right, so we've just heard
about some great APIs and
tools to help you build the
next wave of Android apps.
But we've also been hard at work
helping users discover
all your great existing apps.
As we heard, we've been
successful that way with over
48 billion applications
installed from Google Play.
But our aspirations are
greater than that.
So I'm happy to talk to you
today about some improvements
we're making to Google Play.
We recently launched a
redesigned version of the
Google Play store.
It has a simple clean design
that's designed to scale
effortlessly across phones
and tablets and the web.
Let's take a look at the Play
store on the Nexus 10 tablet.
So here we have the store
on the tablet.
And it's the same content that
you would see on your phone or
anywhere else.
But it's presented in a way
that is much more richly
presented here on the tablet.
The content's organized
into collections.
We have some movie suggestions
there.
But the new Play Store isn't
just about looks.
It's also designed to
help you improve
discovery of your apps.
The Play Store home screen
adapts to you.
So here we see that I've
got some specific
recommendations for me.
I've got a book recommended
based on a previous book.
I'm being recommended the movie
"Inception" because my
buddy Advay +1'd it and
some music and apps
recommendations as well.
But to give you an idea of how
this adapts to different
people, why don't go out on a
limb here a little bit and put
Jai's tablet up side by side so
we can see the difference.
And so here with Jai's tablet,
you see he gets the same types
of recommendations.
He's got movies and music, et
cetera because his friends
have + 1'd things or based on
his previous apps that he's
purchased, et cetera.
But one interesting thing that I
didn't see until now is that
it turns out you're
a Metallica fan?
All right.
We should hang out.
All right, I think we've learned
enough about Jai.
So these personalization
features are going to be
rolling out over the
coming weeks.
But the point is that the new
design of the Play Store gives
us an excellent foundation for
doing even more than what
you've just seen.
So we also know that many of
you have invested a lot of
energy in building awesome
tablet experiences.
And we want to ensure that your
work pays off and that
users are able to discover
your great tablet apps.
So starting today, we're going
to be providing a view in our
top charts that surfaces
applications that are designed
for tablets.
Now, this view here--
thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: This shows apps
that meet our tablet app
design guidelines.
So they target tablet screen
sizes, use the screen real
estate on the tablets
effectively, et cetera.
And as Ellie showed you in the
demo before, in the dev
console you can get hints about
exactly what you should
be doing here if your app needs
some specific tweaks to
meet this criteria.
So I said that this UI scales
across a variety of devices.
So why don't we show you how
we're bringing this to the
rest of Play.
Why don't we pop up
the laptop here.
So over the coming weeks, we're
going to be bringing the
same great Play experience
to the web as well.
You'll notice here that it's
the same consistent design.
We have the same content here
along with my personalized
recommendations.
But it's presented in a way that
really takes great use of
the laptop.
And we also have a new
navigation model here on the
left hand side that easily
allows me to switch between
apps, movies, music,
and books.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: You know, on the
run through we didn't put a
picture of a more handsome man
behind me up on the screen.
But I guess that's fine.
So that's the Play Store.
But the UX isn't just
about the store.
We also want to bring the same
great user experience to all
of the play apps themselves.
So over the coming weeks it's
going to be rolling out to all
the Play apps, books,
movies, magazines
and, of course, music.
So you guys want to
hear about music?
Music unites us.
It's universal.
No matter who you are or where
you're from, the joy of music
is a constant.
And with ubiquitous mobile
devices, there's the potential
to bring that music,
bring that joy with
us wherever we are.
But when a bunch of us on the
Play team got together to talk
about the next generation of
our music service, we all
agreed that the reality was
somewhat different.
Yes, mobile devices give us more
choices than ever before.
But they weren't helping us
discover music we loved.
It felt more like work.
Like, when we were kids,
figuring out what album to
play was an event.
It was a ritual.
So why is it that managing my
que feels like a chore?
So we set out to build a music
service that didn't just give
you access to a world of music
but also helped guide you
through it.
And we started from a
great foundation.
On this very stage two years
ago, we launched our locker
service that allows you to
upload 20,000 of your songs,
stream them across all your
Android devices and the web.
And soon after, we launched our
music store, deals from
all the major labels
and Indies alike.
And so today, users in 13
countries globally are
enjoying their music
on Play music.
But what if we gave you access
to millions of tracks from our
store in addition to your
personal music library?
And what if we combine the power
of Google to understand
what you want to hear and get
you right to the music without
any hassle?
A music service that's about
music, and the technology
fades to the background.
We built that service.
And today I'm happy to announce
Google Play Music All
Access, a uniquely Google
approach to a subscription
music service.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: Why don't we
show it to them, Jai.
Let's pop it up on the phone.
All Access starts
with explore.
It's the guided way for you to
browse am entire collection of
millions of tracks.
And from the moment you enter
explore, we provide
personalized recommendations
based on your listening
preferences.
So here's some of my
personalized recommendations.
We also have a section that we
can swipe over to that shows
featured content, top albums,
and songs as well as playlists
from our staff of music experts
that's always fresh.
But if you want to guide our
assistance, we can swipe over
and look into specific genres.
So we have 22 top level genres
with more to drill into.
And why don't we picked alt
Indie and go in there and show
them what it looks like?
So once we're in here, you see
expert powered recommendations
here, playlists that are curated
by our music editors
as well as top albums from the
genre and key albums that
define the genre.
But like everything in All
Access, anything you see you
can immediately start playing.
So Jai's picked a track
for us here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS YERGA: So,
so far so good.
But here's where the magic
starts because any thing that
I'm listening to in All Access
I can instantly turn into a
radio station.
So Jai hits start radio.
The song keeps playing.
But in the background, All
Access has made us a never
ending mix of related tracks.
Now, if we're curious about
what's coming up, we can swipe
to take a little peek ahead.
But more importantly, we can tap
on the Playlist icon and
see in detail everything that's
coming up and tailor it
to our needs.
So if there's something
there we don't want to
hear, swipe it away.
Swipe it away.
[APPLAUSE]
You want to show them
reordering?
You can also reorder
tracks in the que.
So this is radio
without rules.
It's as lean back as you want
to or as interactive as you
want it to be.
Thank you.
All right, Sometimes you
know exactly what you
want to listen to.
And we're Google.
So there's always search
at the top.
So right now I'm in the mood
for some James Blake.
Why don't you go ahead
and light that up.
And so when-- all right, one
James Blake fan over there.
That's great.
So why don't we pop into
the artist here?
And when we do, we see a couple
of things that are
interesting here about how All
Access blends my catalog with
all the millions of tracks
available to you.
So you see here that there's
one album that I previously
uploaded to the locker
from James Blake.
But if we scroll down, we see
the rest of his tracks and
albums that are available
to me in all
access blended together.
And I notice his most recent
album is available there.
So why don't you go ahead
and tap on that and
add it to my library.
So by adding it to my personal
library, now it shows up here
at the top.
It's easy for me to access
at all times.
My library contains all my
personal music that I uploaded
as well as anything that
I've discovered and
added from all access.
But other times I just want
the music to start.
I want to get to music
with minimal effort.
That's where listen
now comes in.
Listen now brings the power of
Google to surface music we
know you're going to love.
There's always a fresh set
of choices in here.
So in my listen now view, you
see the album I just added as
well as some other tracks that
I've played recently.
There's also new releases from
artists that I enjoy.
And you'll also see interspersed
in here are radio
stations that All Access has
created for us automatically.
With listen now there's always
a great selection of music
available to me for my library
and All Access.
And every day it surprises me.
I can't wait for you all to have
your own magic moments
with listen now.
So so far that's been All
Access on the phone.
But, of course, it works
great on tablet and
web browsers as well.
So why don't we pop
up the laptop?
This is All Access on
the web browser.
As you can see, it has the same
great set of features.
Listen now is here with all my
suggested content, get me one
click to music.
I've got my library, radio,
and, of course, explore.
And I can enjoy All Access
whether I'm on my laptop, on
my tablet, or on my phone.
So to recap, All Access allows
you to explore millions of
tracks effortlessly
on any device.
Radio without rules,
it's completely
interactive if you so choose.
Google powered recommendations
and one click access to your
music from listen now.
And, of course, the best of
both worlds, your personal
library blended with ours.
That's All Access.
Now, there's a lot more
I could show you.
But really I want you all
to try it yourself.
So let's talk about how
you can get it.
All Access is priced at $9.99
a month in the US.
But we're also giving everyone
a 30 day free trial.
[APPLAUSE]
Best of all, its launching
today in the US.
And we'll be rolling out to
additional countries soon.
And if you start a trial
by June 30, you'll pay
only $7.99 a month.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: That's
All Access.
It's been my pleasure
to show it to you.
And now I'm going to call
Hugo back to the stage.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thanks, Chris.
We hope you guys liked
everything you saw here today.
We talked about 900 million
Android, 48 billion app
installs, a bunch of new tools
and developer services that
help you build awesome apps,
find more users around the
world, and, of course, monetize
your hard work.
You also saw the new Google Play
Store as well as a taste
of All Access, the brand new
music experience that's
powered by Google.
One thing we haven't talked
today about yet are devices.
Now, this is not a
device give away.
But I do have a pretty
cool announcement to
share with you guys.
The Android ecosystem is truly
amazing, great hardware and
software experiences, a range
of form factors, and lots of
choice for users including, by
the way, Google's own devices
with the Nexus family that I'm
sure you know quite well.
We continue to be blown away by
the great new devices that
are coming out from our
partners, like, for example
the HTC1 or the Samsung Galaxy
S4, for example.
In fact, just like this
one right here.
Now, there's actually something
a little bit
different about this particular
GS4, for this
particular Galaxy S4 from
Samsung, something that is not
available yet but I want
to show you anyways.
So why don't you take a look
at my home screen?
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: So that's
my home screen.
I've got my Google Apps here
in my Google folder.
If you scroll to the left,
that's my music widget, my
calendar on the other screen.
Go into notifications, a pretty
clean notification
shade and quick settings also
right at your fingertips.
I'm pretty sure you guys are
getting this, right?
What you're seeing
here is real.
This is a Samsung Galaxy S4
running Android 4.2 Jelly Bean
with the same software
experience that was shipped on
our Nexus devices.
It's Google's take on Android.
And it feels really awesome
on the Galaxy S4.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: In fact, this
version of the Samsung Galaxy
S4 will be available directly
through Google Play in the US.
We're selling an unlocked model
that works on both AT&T
and T-Mobile with LTE support,
16 gigabytes of memory,
expandable with a SD
card, of course.
And also it is bootloader
unlocked.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: I knew
you'd like that.
And it will receive system
updates promptly with every
Android platform update.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: This version of the
Samsung Galaxy S4 will be
on sale starting on June 26
on Google Play for $649.
So that's what we have.
It is a spectacular device.
So I want to thank you guys
for your support.
I look forward to talking with
many of you over the next
three days and seeing you
all in the sessions.
And with that, let
me ask Sundar to
come back to the stage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUNDAR PICHAI: We're going to
switch from Android to talk
about our other important
platform, another open
platform, Chrome.
As I said earlier, Chrome
started with the goal to help
make the web better, both
as a platform and as an
experience for users.
It's been an incredible
journey.
We've had amazing adoption
from our users.
And last year at Google I/O we
had reached 450 million or 450
million monthly active users.
We had reported weekly
users before.
But we are switching to monthly
to be consistent with
the rest of this presentation
and industry metrics.
Since then we've had amazing
momentum, and we've added over
300 million new users just in
the last 12 months alone.
And so today we are at
over 750 million
active users of Chrome.
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Chrome
increasingly is
being used on mobile.
What excites us is a lot of this
new growth is coming on
phones and tablets.
We launched Chrome both
for Android and iOS.
And we are just beginning
to start pushing
the mobile web forward.
A lot of what you'll hear today
is about how we can push
the mobile web forward.
It is in its early days.
But we think we can do to the
mobile web what we did for the
desktop web.
Chrome also serves as the
foundation for Chrome OS, a
computing system designed
for and but
entirely around the web.
And we brought a lot of it
together last October by
launching the Samsung
Chromebook, what we viewed as
the perfect additional computer
for everyone.
At $249, it was thin,
light, portable.
And people are buying it as
the second, third, fourth
computer in their homes.
It's been over 200 days
since launched.
And it's been number one on
Amazon in laptops for 190
consecutive days in
that time window.
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: It is an
ecosystem play, and we have
many more partners joining
our journey.
Acer, Lenovo, HP are all
shipping Chromebooks now.
And we're expanding our
presence in retail.
Two months ago we
also announced
the Chromebook Pixel.
The goal behind the Pixel was
literally to design the best
laptop out there possible.
The screen on this laptop
is gorgeous.
It's the highest resolution
display that's ever
shipped on a laptop.
And it has full touch enable.
Its precision engineered with
the best custom components
available out there.
Our goal with the Pixel was
to get it in the hands of
developers so that they can
build the next generation of
web experiences.
We're going to have a lot more
to talk about Chrome OS later
this year, and we are really
investing a lot in this area.
But I want to come back to
Chrome for a minute.
We talked about how in this
multi-screen world people are
using different types
of devices,
including phones and tablets.
With Chrome, our goal has been
to make sure it's your web.
You sign into Chrome, you get
your experience consistently
across all your devices,
your web everywhere
personalized for you.
And to do that well,
we really need to
take mobile web forward.
So we're going to show you an
example of how the mobile web
is evolving.
What we are about to show you
is a preview which Warner
Brothers and the developers
at North Kingdom have put
together for the upcoming
"Hobbit" movie.
And Kan is going to
help me with this.
We're going to get this
up on screen.
This is running on a
Pixel right now.
And as you can see, this is
what the web shines for.
They want a trailer.
They want a preview
for their movie.
You're not going to write an
app and get everyone to
install an app on every
one of their devices.
You write a web experience and
you expect people to use it
independent of the
device they have.
So it's on a Pixel.
Thanks to HTML 3D CSS, you
can see it works great.
Kan can touch and move around.
The clouds look great.
And it works really well.
So far, not that surprising.
But we're going to
switch now from a
Chromebook Pixel to a tablet.
And we're going to show Chrome
running on Nexus 10.
And you can see there is no
difference in the experience.
A lot of what we're going to
talk about today is the same
capabilities which you're used
to on the Chrome on desktop
are all coming to Chrome
on Android.
So it feels exactly the same way
you would see on a Pixel
on a Nexus 10 as well.
Let's dive in deeper.
Kan is going to start playing
a game on the Nexus 10.
And I guess the goal of this
game is for hobbits to avoid
being eaten by the trolls.
It's a new game upcoming.
It is a 3D game.
And it's based on WebGL.
Can we get the game
up on screen?
We can see it there.
And we are running this, again,
on Chrome on Nexus 10.
And the reason we are able
to play this game
is thanks to WebGL.
This wasn't possible on
the web last year.
And you will hear the
search team--
OK, so we have it up
and running now.
Kan's goal is to avoid the
trolls and not be eaten for
dinner as a hobbit.
I guess he lost very,
very quickly there.
[LAUGHTER]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Look, Web GL is
something new to Chrome, and
it makes this experience
possible.
You will say Google Maps team
talk later in the presentation
about how they're using WebGL.
Let's show you one more thing.
We're going to zoom in the map
in Middle Earth in a place
called Rivendell.
All this is happening on mobile,
Chrome on mobile.
Kan is going to start swiping
his way through.
Thanks to web audio APIs, as
he gestures around on his
touch screen, the
music changes.
And you can see how the
experience is very
interactive.
There's touch and web
audio APIs working
together on the web.
I think you can really start
creating powerful experiences
on the web and increasingly run
it on phones and tablets.
And we are making a lot
of progress there.
So I'm going to invite Linus
Upson onto the stage to talk
in detail about all the
APIs we are adding
to the mobile web.
Linus.
[APPLAUSE]
LINUS UPSON: So just a few weeks
ago the web celebrated
its 20th birthday.
And the unique properties that
transformed desktop computing
from the web, the fact that
everything is a link,
everything is searchable by
default, makes it possible
with just a few key strokes
for anyone in the world to
find billions of different
web pages.
Applications, video content is
instantly discoverable and
shareable, no need to
install software, no
need to update software.
And on the Chrome team, our
goal is to make the web
better, both on desktop and on
mobile, better for users and
better for developers.
But that doesn't mean
loading the
browser up full of features.
The browser's a means,
not an end.
And so we're always trying to
figure out how to make the
browser smaller and faster.
So we focus on three
things, speed
simplicity, and security.
And we're bringing that
same focus to mobile.
Let's take a look at speed
to start with.
When we first launched Chrome,
it's JavaScript engine V8 was
20 times faster than anything
else out there.
And in the four and a half years
since, we've continued
to make it faster still.
Just in the last year you can
see we've improved performance
of V8 by almost 25%
on the desktop.
But the games on mobile
are even bigger.
In the last year we've seen
the performance improve by
more than 50% on mobile.
These are the kinds
of things--
[APPLAUSE]
LINUS UPSON: These are the kinds
of things that enable
the next generation of the
mobile web and of mobile web
applications.
Of course, the V8 team is always
looking to optimize new
use cases because people are
always pushing JavaScript in
new directions.
Recently Mozilla introduced a
very clever way to compile C
or C++ code down into a subset
of JavaScript called ASM.js.
And this has gotten a lot of
attention recently because it
allows you to then access all of
that code that you have in
C and C++ and be able to
run it on the web.
And this is JavaScript that's
not written by humans.
It's written by compilers.
So it looks very different than
the kind of JavaScript
we've optimized for
in the past.
And in the last month alone,
we've gotten over 2.4 times
speed boost running this
ASM.js code in V8.
And there's tons more
optimization to come.
But, of course, JavaScript is
only one component of speed.
When you download a web page,
more than 60&% of the bytes
that come across your internet
connection are images.
And it's growing.
So we've developed an open
source royalty free
compression technology
called WebP.
So these two images here, you
see the one on the left as
JPEG, the one on the
right is WebP.
They're both at the
same quality.
But let's take a look
at the sizes.
The WebP image is 30%
smaller than a JPEG
image at the same quality.
The benefits of this for image
rich websites is compelling.
It saves on bandwidth.
It saves on power, particularly
on mobile
computing devices.
And we're seeing it adopted by
properties like Google+, like
Facebook, particularly
on their mobile apps.
Oh.
So WebP supports not only
lossless compression, but also
lossy compression, transparency,
color profiles,
metadata and, unfortunately,
animated images as well.
[APPLAUSE]
LINUS UPSON: So you can use WebP
to replace JPEGs, PNGs,
as well as animated GIFs.
I'm sorry.
Of course, videos are a
big part of the web.
By the end of 2012, over
half of mobile
internet traffic was video.
We need to make videos
smaller.
With WebM, we've created an open
royalty free container
media file format for the web.
So let's take a look
at two videos.
One of these is encoded in 264,
which is probably what
you're seeing today
on the web.
The other is encoded in WebM's
next generation codec, VP9.
The bar charts show you
the real time bit
rate of the two videos.
When we get to the end, we'll
see what the sizes of each are
and how much smaller VP9 is.
For this particular video--
[APPLAUSE]
LINUS UPSON: For
this particular
video, VP9 was 63% smaller.
Running across a wide range of
videos and a wide range of
resolutions, we see about a
50% reduction in size with
VP9, which is a huge
bandwidth savings.
So if you're paying money for
your mobile data plan, this is
enormous for you.
And it's great to see that
YouTube is going to be rolling
out support for VP9
later this year.
Now, of course, we want all
websites to take advantage of
these new technologies.
But until they're everywhere,
what we've done is we've built
a data compression proxy
for Chrome for mobile.
And you can see here it's
easy to turn on.
You can go to bandwidth
management
to reduce data usage.
And it shows you how much data
you're actually saving.
So let's take a look at the real
data for one user here.
They save 46% of their data over
the course of a month.
And when we've been running
this in the Android beta
channel-- and many of you can
try it out right now--
we see an average of about
50% data compression.
We rewrite the HTML, CSS, and
JavaScript to make it smaller.
We transform images into WebP.
And we speak the SPDY network
protocol to get you fewer bits
faster but get you all the bits
from the web page that
you're looking for.
So beyond just making web pages
faster, we want to make
things faster and simpler
for users.
One of the hardest things you
can do on your phone today is
buy something.
The average checkout
process is about 21
steps on your phone.
So it's no surprise that the
abandonment rate of shopping
carts on mobile phones
is around 97%.
We can do much better
than this.
So by building on the existing
HTML5 auto complete spec,
we've built something in Chrome,
both on desktop and in
mobile, that collects all of
your payment information when
you enter it anywhere, syncs it
across all of your devices.
So now when you come to check
out on a website, you press
check out, you see this form.
Chrome already knows all of
your payment information.
It shows it to you in a form.
You can look at it and you say,
yep, that's what I want.
And you click Submit
and you're done.
So this is going to make
shopping from your phone much,
much easier.
[APPLAUSE]
LINUS UPSON: And there's a
session, if you want to learn
more about this, later today.
It's called--
I bet it has payments
in the name.
I forgot what it is.
But it's on the calendar
for today.
Standardizing payments
on the web.
OK, so not just programs, not
just users, but we also want
to make developers more
productive and make life
simpler for them as well.
So for the last couple of years
we've been working on
some new fundamental technology
in the web platform
called web components.
For the first time you're going
to be able to build your
own HTML tags.
You can build your own HTML tags
by taking smaller bits of
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript and
putting them into a first
class component.
And that component can be
reshared between applications,
between phones, between tablets,
between desktops so
that you can be much more
productive and have
applications that are much more
delightful for users.
We're also working on the first
tool kit to natively
take advantage of
web components.
And in this tool kit it really
captures the modern, elegant
design philosophy you've been
seeing in a lot of the recent
Google applications,
particularly the mobile ones.
This tool kit project actually
has been open
source since the beginning.
And some of you have stumbled
upon it and found it.
But it's still very early.
But the vision for
it is clear.
We want this elegant UI
framework that works across
all form factors, all devices.
And we put together a short
video to give you an idea
about where we're going
with the toolkit.
Let's play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
LINUS UPSON: So you can see our
goal here really is to be
able to allow developers like
you create your own tags,
reuse them in a way that makes
sense on a phone, be able to
take that same component, reuse
it on a tablet, combine
them in different ways for
desktop applications.
And it's something that's
tremendously exciting.
It's still early, as I said.
It's not ready for consumption
by regular developers.
But if you're interested in
learning more about where
we're going and help us to find
the vision of the future,
please come to the web
components in action session
on Thursday.
Now, we've been talking today a
lot about Chrome across all
of your different screens.
So why not build a fun
experience to show that off?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LINUS UPSON: So Racer is a
multiplayer, multi-screen
experiment.
And all you need to
play is Chrome.
Regardless of device Android or
iOS, phone or tablet, you
just need to click a link
and get started.
So we've got some volunteers to
come help us show it off.
So while they're coming up,
why don't we take a closer
look at the devices here?
We have a ring around
the team.
This is Arno Weber who manages
the Chrome Mobile team.
He's an actual race
car driver.
We'll see how he does in
the electronic form.
So this game is a simple
little racing game.
I don't know if you remember
the little slot car racing
games when you were a kid?
You pull the trigger, zoom
around the track.
But if you go too fast,
the car spins out.
That's essentially what these
guys are going to
be trying to do.
So are we ready to switch
to the overhead?
Thanks.
So, Ken, take it away.
KEN LIU: Great.
Thanks, Linus.
OK, so this game is
really simple.
Once I start the game, all you
have to do is press down to
accelerate and let
go to decelerate.
Basically, when you go around
the corners, you don't want to
be going too fast.
So I'm going to start a race
here and I'm going to join it
from these devices.
OK, let me click Start.
You know, you guys look
like professionals.
So I'm going to click
Ridiculous.
We're going to go ridiculous
on this one guys.
LINUS UPSON: I predict lots of
cars will fly off the track.
KEN LIU: All right,
so pick your cars.
Are you going to use this one?
OK.
Then I'm going to use
the iOS device.
And tap when you're ready.
Let's get this game started.
You might not want
to hold on yet.
[LAUGHTER]
KEN LIU: Getting a little
ahead of ourselves.
LINUS UPSON: Ready, set, go.
Oh, the first car goes
spinning off.
[SOUND EFFECTS]
LINUS UPSON: Now, this
game is running on
Google Compute Engine.
And it's able to keep all the
different devices in sync
using WebSockets.
KEN LIU: No, stop
running into me.
LINUS UPSON: And it uses Web
Audio as the sound transitions
between all of the different
devices.
Oh, someone's made it
around a full lap.
[SOUND EFFECTS]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, shoot.
[LAUGHTER]
KEN LIU: I'm going to win.
Come on.
I didn't practice all these
days for nothing.
LINUS UPSON: This is just as
hard as I remember those
little racing games as a kid.
KEN LIU: Yes.
That was a close one.
[APPLAUSE]
KEN LIU: Are you
guys giving up?
Still two people are
not finished.
LINUS UPSON: There's still
two people out there?
KEN LIU: That's all right.
It's all right.
I think we got enough.
We got the point.
LINUS UPSON: Who
came in first?
Ken.
Congratulations.
He's been practicing
this all week.
Anyway, thank you all for
helping with that.
[APPLAUSE]
LINUS UPSON: Anyway, we hope
you're all excited, as we are,
about where the mobile
web is headed.
And to celebrate the first 20
years of the wen, we've put
together this short film showing
how far we've come.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SUNDAR PICHAI: It's inspiring
to see the 20 year
story of the web.
It's truly one of the most
amazing software platforms
we've seen in our lives.
Before we move on, let's get a
picture of the Pixel back up
on the screen.
I'm also going to
go pick one up.
As I said earlier, the goal
behind the Pixel was to
literally build the best laptop
possible out there.
You guys have any idea why we
have it up on the screen and
I'm holding one up in my hand?
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: We're going to
give each and every one of you
a brand new Pixel.
I've been asked to say it's
not ready until 2:00 PM.
So please don't leave in the
middle of the Keynote.
But we're very excited.
Our goal behind the Pixel was
to make sure that developers
had a chance to get the web
ready for the next generation
experience with full touch
and high resolution.
So I can't wait to see what
you all to do with it.
We're incredibly excited.
A lot of us use it as our
day to day computer.
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: So we've talked
about Android and Chrome.
And our goal behind these
platforms is to make sure
developers can build amazing
experiences on
top of these platforms.
We want to now give you a real
life example of how this all
comes together.
And we're going to do
that by talking
about education briefly.
A lot of us at Google are
deeply passionate about
education because it's an area
where we can really see the
impact technology can have on
people's lives, especially the
lives of children.
And so we are investing
a lot in education.
And for us, the journey started
with Google Apps.
Google Apps are incredibly
popular in
schools around the world.
There are over 25 million users
of Google Apps in over
200 countries all around the
world, in schools, in
universities, and so on.
Just in the United States, 74
of the top 100 universities
fully run on Google Apps.
Seven of the eight Ivy
League universities--
for those of you who are from
Dartmouth, you may want to
start nudging your IT
administrator there.
But seven of the eight
Ivy League
schools use Google Apps.
Large public school systems
like Chicago, et cetera,
completely run on Google Apps.
And the momentum
is incredible.
But we want to take
it a step further.
What we want to do is to bring
both Android and Chrome into
educational institutions around
the world so that both
Google and all of you can build
applications to really
change how computing and
technology is used in schools.
We are beginning to invest a lot
for Android in education.
And we want to give
you an update.
To do that, I'm going
to invite Chris
Yerga back on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: Thanks, Sundar.
So as we've heard, Android is
growing incredibly fast.
And its momentum is changing
everything.
But there's still a big part
of all of our lives and the
lives of our kids that
mobile technology
hasn't really touched.
When I go visit my kids'
classrooms, it looks pretty
much exactly like it did
when I went to school.
So a bunch of us in Android
asked educators why is there
so much talk about technology
in schools
but so little impact?
And what we heard was
really interesting.
Teachers told us that in
education there's a huge gap
between what's possible with
technology and what's
practical, especially with
mobile technology.
And then they told us it was
Google's job to fix this.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS YERGA: Google should make
it affordable to give
every student a tablet.
And Google should make it so
that it's not so crazy to
manage all those devices.
And Google, finally, should make
it way easier to find the
best tools and content from
a really diverse set of
developers and get that content
to the right students.
We agreed.
So today I'm really excited to
announce a new initiative,
which will make it easy and
affordable for schools to put
Android tablets in the hands of
all their kids and to load
them up with powerful
educational content and tools.
And I want to give you a sneak
peak of one of the key parts
of this effort, Google Play for
Education, built from the
ground up to meet the unique
content needs of educators.
Let's take a look.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: So the first thing
you'll notice is that
Google Play for Education is
organized by categories
educators care about,
namely subject
matter and grade level.
For example, say I'm the K-6
math subject matter expert in
my school district.
And I want to find an
educational app that my
incoming kindergartners can use
to sharpen their problem
solving skills.
So I click on Math,
Kindergarten.
And immediately I see a bunch of
apps from a diverse set of
partners, including
NASA and PBS.
Also, each app has been
recommended by a group of
educators as useful for teaching
kindergarten math.
This is key because teachers
trust other teachers.
So Kids Numbers and Math from
Intellijoy looks really good.
I'll start with the
free version.
Remember, I'm not shopping
for myself here.
Because this school is using
Google Apps for Education and
every student has a Google
account, I can just enter the
name of the Google group of
these students and, bam, all
500 kindergartners in my
district will instantly get
this app on their tablets.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: Now say a few weeks
have gone by and I'm
really impressed with the math
skills that kids are learning
from Kids Numbers and Math.
So I want to upgrade to
the paid version so
the kids can go deeper.
Rather than enter a credit card,
which is not how schools
work, I can just charge these
500 licenses against a balance
funded by a school
purchase order.
And one more thing, notice
that the store
doesn't just have apps.
You can discover books and
YouTube educational videos and
push them to Android tablets
in exactly the same way.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: Pilot sites like
Kipp Bridge Charter School and
Hillsborough Township Public
Schools are already going
crazy for this.
Six elementary schools in New
Jersey used 550 different
third party apps during a single
day in our pilot, all
of them discovered and
downloaded by teachers in
Google Play for Education.
Multiply that pilot by millions
of classrooms in the
US and you can see there's a
huge opportunity here for
educators, students, and
for you as developers.
So this is where you come in.
We're doing the heavy lifting
of building Play for
Education, bringing it to the
schools, making it easy for
them to find great content
and buy it in bulk.
Now you can focus on what you do
best, creating awesome and
innovative educational
content.
We're going to be launching
Google Play for
Education in the fall.
But starting this summer, we'll
be ready to accept your
app submissions.
Check out our developer
micro site at
developer.android.com/edu where
we've posted guidelines
on how to build awesome
K-12 apps.
Also, come find us at the
education sandbox here at I/O.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: It's great to see
Android making it's foray
into education.
We're going to invest a lot.
We've already been doing
this with Chromebooks.
Chromebooks are really ideally
suited for education because
this literally no set up,
no administration.
You open the device, you're good
to go, and you have the
power of web within you.
Just last year alone, we had
over 1,000 schools in the
United States running
Chromebooks.
In the four months this year,
we've added 2,000 new schools
and Chromebooks are going
mainstream in education in
schools in the United States
just like Google Apps.
And the area where this
all came together
beautifully is Malaysia.
So I want to talk about
that for a minute.
Malaysia has a nationalized
education system.
They have 10,000 schools in
the country distributed,
several of them in poor,
rural areas.
So they really wanted to provide
for 4G connectivity
throughout to all 10,000
schools to
level the playing field.
And they're deploying Google
Apps along with Chromebooks in
primary and secondary schools
so that they can bring
computing in their schools.
So let's take a look at
what they're doing.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Malaysia has so
much to offer.
There's so much untapped
potential.
Just to walk into one of these
small villages and look at the
eyes of those children in that
school, you see that spark,
little fire in their eyes.
There's this whole world out
there that would allow you to
experience learning
beyond what you
ever thought possible.
-And a lot of our students don't
have internet access.
A lot of them were
just left behind.
-In Malaysia we place a huge
investment in the education of
our young children.
-We're providing 4G connectivity
to all schools
across the country.
And the fact that we can
spread it across 10,000
schools is amazing.
-Learning had to be
anytime, anyplace.
You didn't have to be in a state
of the art classroom.
But you could be with a
chromebook sitting in a field
and experiencing world
class learning.
-It is so exciting
to be a part of
education in Malaysia today.
This power that you place in a
child's hand and you say, the
web is your school.
Go and learn.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Look, to me and
to a lot of us, this is what
the journey of computing
is about.
What we are doing in eduction
on top of platforms like
Android and Chrome, we can do
it for users everywhere,
including the other five billion
people on the planet.
Android and Chrome are designed
for not just Google,
but for you all to create
amazing experiences.
We're going to switch now and
talk about what we are doing
on Google, what we call as the
best of Google on top of
Android and Chrome.
You're going to hear from three
teams, from the Google+
team, from the Search team,
and from the Maps team.
And we'll get things started
with Vic Gundotra and Google+.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Among the most basic of human
needs is the need to connect
with others.
With a smile or laugh, we
connect with people every
single day.
But the meaning of our real
world connections often gets
lost online.
And so began the Google+
project to help make
connecting online more like
we do in real life.
So you can share the things you
love with the people you
love and get closer to the
people you care about, make
discoveries, explore the stuff
you're into, and get together.
-So everybody say hi.
That's the whole world.
-Hi.
-Can I hug you?
-Yeah.
-We're the first ones that
are doing it like this.
It's history.
-Look, you guys have the
greatest technology at your
fingertips.
-We have a boy.
-Thanks, everybody.
-This a celebration.
Y'all is invited.
[END VIDEO PLAY BACK]
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: We are incredibly
grateful to the
hundred and millions of you out
there who joined Google+
in just under two short years.
And we can think of no better
way to say thank you than to
continue to innovate and to
build a product that people
truly love.
And so I'm here to show you
what's next with Google+.
Today we're introducing 41 new
features across three major
areas of Google+.
First, a newly designed
stream, a new Hangout
application, and a fundamentally
new photos
experience.
We have a lot to talk about.
Let's get started.
Let's begin with the Stream.
Now, it's no surprise that
mobile devices are
increasingly prevalent and
important in our lives.
It's the computer that's
with us all the time.
And so the Google+ has spent a
lot of time making sure that
that core stream experience on
mobile absolutely rocks.
And the feedback has
been fantastic.
And so today we're taking that
multicolumn design and
bringing it to lots
more devices.
Yes, from your phone to your
tablet and even your desktop,
you're going to see a newly
designed stream.
We're also fixing a longstanding
problem with
today's social streams and
that's they're flat.
It's very easy to see a long
list of things that have been
shared with you, kind of like
a never ending newspaper.
But it's nearly impossible to
go deeper on a topic or
interest that you might have.
And we think we can fix that.
So this new design, this
new stream, is
about design and depth.
Maybe the best thing to
do is just show you.
What you're looking
at is Google+ as
it exists this morning.
What you're going to see start
rolling out later today is the
new Google+, which
looks like this.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: You can see, we've
taken that multicolumn
design and brought it to the
desktop and really made
something beautiful.
It's dynamic, meaning depending
upon the size of
your screen, it can either be
one column, two column, or
three columns.
And we've made sure to
give you choice.
So if you go into the More menu,
you're always able to go
to a single column if that's
what you prefer.
Of course, in this multicolumn
design, we've made sure that
posts like photos and videos
can span multiple columns.
So you get something that's
truly immersive.
And we made sure that it's
fast, fluid, and fun.
And so we put delightful
animations
throughout the product.
For example, a share box that
animates out, menus that slide
in and out to get out of the
way, and even cards and that
flip and fade beautifully.
Yeah, it's pretty amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: But it's not
just about the design.
It's about depth.
As I mentioned earlier, it's
very difficult to go deeper on
a topic or interest
you care about.
We think we've solved
this problem.
And today we're introducing
related hashtags.
What we'll do is we'll analyze
the content of a post.
And Google will put on the
appropriate hashtag.
How does that work?
Well, let's take a look.
Here's a post about
the San Francisco
Giants baseball team.
It's not just about
the Giants.
It's about Buster Posey, a
particular player, as well.
And note in the top, we've
automatically tagged that post
and we know it's about
those two topics.
But that's only half
of the magic.
We also then rank and
search the entire
universe of Google+ content.
And we rank it just for you.
So when Matt clicks
on one of those
hashtags, watch what happens.
We flip the card over and we
then show you related items
from the most important
sources and social
proximity to you.
Amazing, isn't it?
[APPLAUSE].
VIC GUNDOTRA: Now, if you think
that's impressive, let's
take a look at another one
of these problems.
In this case, one of the noted
photographers on our service
has posted a picture
of Paris, and
particularly the Eiffel Tower.
Nowhere in his post or
in the comments is
the word Eiffel Tower.
But if you notice, Google has
automatically hashtaged this
with the Eiffel Tower.
How did we do that?
Well, we did image analysis
and combined with the
Knowledge Graph that
recognizes important landmarks.
And Google knew that this was
about the Eiffel Tower.
So if you click, why, you can
just go deeper and click
through other posts about
the Eiffel Tower.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: Now, of
course, we deeply
respect the content producer.
And so you always have the
option of telling Google,
either on a particular post or
globally, whether you want
your content to have
this amazing
related hashtags feature.
And if we ever get it wrong and
have the wrong hashtag,
you could always X it out.
In either case, we think what
we've built here is a stream
that's about design and depth,
really allowing you to go
deeper on your interests.
Now, we don't have time to show
you all of the features.
There's just too many
to talk about today.
But we'll be rolling this
out this afternoon.
We hope that you'll absolutely
love it.
OK, now let's talk
about Hangouts.
You know, at Google we have a
point of view about software
and technology, namely that it
should get out of the way and
allow people to do what
they do best, that's
live, learn, and love.
That was true even when
we started Google+.
You know, other sites when we
started often asked you to
think of your relationships as
either friends or not friends.
And we argued that was not
reflective of real life.
In real life you don't
have this.
You have this.
And so we built circles as
a core part of Google+.
And we're happy to report that
today more than half of all
sharing that's done on Google+
is done to private circles.
Now, that same dynamic exists
in the world of real time
communications.
When you think about a real time
communication, somebody
you want to talk with, you don't
think about wanting to
talk to a computer.
You want to talk to a person.
And yet despite 50 years
of work in real time
communication products, we still
are stuck with gadgets
that get in the way.
Think for a moment about
some of the real time
communications products, the
choices that you have.
Some are very nice.
They work on one platform.
So if you think about your
friend, you have to ask
yourself are they on a
particular operating system?
Why you should OS's matter?
People matter.
Or think about other choices
that are very popular on
mobile, fantastic ways to
communicate on mobile.
But if your brother is at work
on a desktop or a laptop, why
should he be left out?
Or there are other solutions
that do group video very, very
well and messaging.
But it's very difficult
to do photos.
Frankly, even Google's own
services have been fragmented
and confused at times.
What we want to do is fill
in all the boxes.
Because when we fill in all
the boxes, we believe,
finally, technology can just go
away and people can focus
on what makes them
the happiness.
And that's just hanging out.
So we're introducing today a
new application, Hangouts.
And we think we've built
a product that is about
conversations that last with
people that you love.
Let me show you the product.
Now, as Matt goes to the demo
here, the first thing you'll
notice on Matt's Android
phone is the new icon,
a standalone app.
And Matt will go ahead and click
on Hangouts and open up
the application.
Now, you're looking
here at a list of
conversations, not contacts.
Some of those conversations
or one on one.
are group conversations.
But the primary pivot,
the focus is on those
conversations.
Now, if Matt wants to get his
contacts, maybe he wants to
add someone, it's
one tap away.
You can see Google will rank the
important people that he
normally talks to and make
that easily available for
either a message or
a video call.
But let's go back to
the conversations.
There's several attributes about
these conversations that
I want to talk about.
The first is my favorite.
And that is these
conversations can be long lasting.
So as Matt goes back in time,
you're able to see that
conversation.
Imagine that you have your
family in a conversation for
many months or a year.
There's the holiday party.
There's the vacation
you took together.
There's important moments like
the birth of a child.
All those things are stored with
you even as you change
devices in those long running
conversations.
Of course, we give you the
ability to turn off history.
Of course, we give you
the ability to
delete those things.
But having the ability to save
those conversations is, I
think, delightful and amazing.
Another aspect is that
the conversations
are rich and alive.
Your photos are stored
in albums.
This is amazing.
This baby's not even three
months old and he's already
learned how to face pump.
But all the images that you've
shared as a family are all
right there.
In addition to beautiful images
that are easily stored
and saved, the conversation
feels alive.
Look at the bottom.
You can there see as people
join, they show up.
As they're typing,
they animate out.
You can see exactly where
someone has read to.
It really feels like you're
in the same room together.
And we think that's
delightful.
By the way, you're looking at
it on the way web, you're
looking at it on Android, and
you're looking at it on iOS,
all available today.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: And, by the
way, two other points.
One is a point that Hugo made.
I think you're going
to love how the
notifications are all synced.
So if you wipe a notification
from the desktop or on
Android, it'll go away
on another device.
It's beautiful.
I think you'll like that.
But my favorite feature--
sorry about that.
Let's go back to the demo.
One other feature I didn't talk
about that was pretty
critical, which is at Google
we always believed that the
best way to do real time
communications is
face to face to face.
And so in that conversation,
Matt can tap on that video
icon and everyone in that
conversation will be dropped
into a video chat.
There, you can see Matt.
He's into the video chat and
everyone's being dropped in.
Group video at no charge.
Isn't that fantastic?
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: OK, let's
go back to the slides.
OK, now let's switch topics.
And, finally, let's
talk about photos.
Photography can be a very
rewarding experience.
I know for me it captures
the most important
moments of my life.
I remember when I was on the
beach and I asked my kids to
stand together to
take a picture.
I didn't know my son was
going to wrap his
arms around my daughter.
I didn't know my daughter
was going to reach up
and hold his hand.
But for the rest of my life I'm
going to picture them like
this despite the fact that
he's now taller than me.
That's how I imagine him.
I'm not alone.
You too have amazing images that
are the most important
precious memories
of your life.
But if we're honest with each
other, we'll also admit that
photography is very
labor intensive.
It takes a lot of time to
organize, edit, enhance,
upload and share your
photos, time that
many of us don't have.
At Google we think we can give
you some of your time back.
By combining your camera with
our cloud, we can do some of
those labor intensive tasks
automatically for you.
In fact, today we'd like to
introduce the notion of
Google's data centers being
your new darkroom.
Now, what does that mean?
Well, when you think of
the cloud, most of us
think of back up.
But today we're going to go
beyond back up, and we're
going to talk about three
exciting new areas that
combine the data center,
Google's cloud, with
photography.
But before I do that, let me
just begin with what you
already know, back up.
Now, since we've launched
Google+, we've always backed
up your photos, unlimited, all
your photos at standard size.
And a few months ago we
introduced the ability for you
to choose an option where we
would upload your photos, not
at standard size, but
at full resolution.
And we offered 5
gigabytes free.
This week we announced that
we're going from 5 gigabytes
to 15 gigabytes free.
Now, why does full resolution
matter?
Well, what you're looking
at here is an
eight megapixel shot.
An eight megapixel shot--
you can clap if you
want, go ahead.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: I love it when
you clap and I haven't even
made the point on the slide.
That's great.
But I think you get it.
Eight megapixels is
pretty common.
Some cell phones like the
Galaxy S4 go up to 13
megapixels.
And when you have an important
image, you don't want 619
pixels or 1024 or 2048.
80 You want all the pixels
because some memories are not
meant to be downsized.
And we give you that
ability on Google+.
Let's move on.
Now let's talk about
Highlight.
What you're looking at is 686 of
my vacation photos from my
trip to New Zealand.
Now, there are some beautiful
images in there,
images I want to share.
But I don't have time to
pick them out because
my vacation is over.
[LAUGHTER]
VIC GUNDOTRA: Now, I suspect
you've been in the same boat.
It takes time do
all this stuff.
Google can pick the best
pictures for you.
We can go from these 686
pictures to these.
It's remarkably accurate.
Go ahead.
You can clap.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: Some of you must
be saying, how did Google know
those were the best?
Let me tell you.
We do lots of things
to choose the best.
Some of things that we
do is we look for
images that are blurry.
And they're not going to
make the highlights.
We look for images that
are duplicates.
I took four images of
the same mountain.
We'll pick one.
We look for images that are not
the greatest exposure and
they're unlikely to make
your highlights.
Or we even do amazing
things like we
recognize the Eiffel Tower.
We can recognize in your
images if you're at an
important landmark.
In this case, this is a
beautiful shot of Queenstown.
And we boost that image so that
it's more likely to make
the highlights.
We also analyze to see if
there are people there.
Are the people happy?
Are they smiling?
Might make the highlights.
Our machine learning algorithms
have also been
trained by literally hundreds
of human raters so that the
machine learning algorithms have
now begun to account for
aesthetics, for human taste.
What do people find beautiful?
And we're able to boost
that image.
And then my favorite
is affinity.
We recognize who's important
to you, who's
in your family circle.
And we apply appropriate social
boost so that you're
wife and your children are
in the highlights.
It's absolutely amazing.
We think you're going
to love it.
And it's going to
save you time.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: This is
a shot of what we're
rolling out this evening.
This is the actual product,
the desktop version.
You'll note that we'll give
you your highlights.
And right there at the bottom
you could always click and see
all the other images as well.
So it's right there for you.
Now let's talk about enhancing
your images.
One of my favorite photographers
famously said,
you don't take a photograph.
You make it.
And if you know a good
photographer, a professional,
you know that's true.
Professionals can take a good
image and make it amazing
because they have access to
tools like this, powerful
tools that require lots of
skills that run on expensive
machines that take
lots of time.
And you can do amazing things.
The problem is is that for the
average person these tools
often look like this to them,
like a bewildering set of
knobs that they don't
understand.
Today we're introducing
auto enhance.
Auto enhance is an easy
button to make your
memories look beautiful.
We can automatically take an
image that looks like this and
make it look like this.
Now, how in the world
do we do that?
Well, we're going to show you
some of the things that we do,
things like tonal distribution,
skin softening,
noise reduction, structure,
vignetting, red eye reduction,
so much that we do.
And we don't have time
in his keynote to
show you all of them.
But we're going to
highlight a few.
Let's begin with tonal
distribution.
All of us have taken
pictures that are
over or under exposed.
You might think Google would
find the middle ground.
We do better than that.
Remember, our algorithms take
into account human taste.
So we can take an image like
this and just make it perfect.
Let me show you another
example.
Let's talk about
skin softening.
Now, I'm going to apologize in
advance because you're going
to see a huge photo of me.
But we thought we'd pick someone
that no one could get
offended over.
So we'll start that with me.
OK, now let's talk about
recognizing people's faces.
If you have an inexpensive phone
or even an inexpensive
camera, those devices
can recognize faces.
But the state of the art today
is to put a rectangle around a
face and say, we think
there's a face there.
We've had several breakthroughs
at Google where
we're now able to deeply
recognize the
human face and skin.
We can tease apart exactly
where is the hairline.
What are the eyes, the teeth?
Is the person wearing jewelry?
Do they have glasses on?
And we can separate
all that out.
That breakthrough means that
when we do the other effects,
things like structure, tonal
enhancement, we can do
something different
on the clouds,
the water, the mountains.
And we can treat the human face
completely separately
like a professional
would in a tool.
Now, let's talk about one
of those effects.
Let's talk about
skin softening.
Now, how many of you like your
passport or your driver's
license photos?
No one does.
Well, why not?
Because photographs often
exaggerate our flaws.
In real life when you look at me
or your friends, you don't
see every one of their flaws.
But in a picture, you
see all of them.
In fact, we're going
to make it worse.
Let's zoom in on this picture
a little bit.
Like I said, I used my own so I
wouldn't offend anyone else.
Wrinkles, right?
But chances are when you're
talking to me, you
don't stare at them.
Watch what happens when we apply
skin softening, just
gently toned down.
Let's zoom all the way out.
That's the original image.
That's with skin softening
enhancements.
Just gently and beautifully
enhanced.
We think you're going to love
it when we apply this across
your photographs.
Let's talk about noise
reduction.
Maybe you've taken a picture
in low light, particularly
with a cell phone.
You get grain, noise
on your image.
Look at the sky in
this photograph.
Well, our noise reduction
filters can automatically take
something that looks like this
and make it look like that.
Pretty amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's talk about structure.
Here's a picture that I took
when I was in New Zealand.
I remember that image
having more life.
It was more vivid.
Well, what happened?
Well, the camera palette
balanced everything out so it
became flat.
A professional would go into a
tool and they would add a lot
more structure to the sky.
We can do that automatically.
And so we can take an image that
looks like this and auto
enhance it to look like that.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: There's obviously
lots more that we
don't have time to talk about.
But what we're going to
bring up a special
tool, a debugging tool.
And we're going to tease apart
some of these effects and show
you how they layer on to
make an image awesome.
So here's an image, untouched
out of the camera.
And we're going to start
layering on these
enhancements.
Let's begin with tonal
enhancement.
Let's add some skin softening.
Before and after on the
skin softening.
Now let's add some structure
for the clouds.
Let's add vignette to emphasize
the human face.
And let's go before and then
auto enhanced by Google.
Pretty amazing, isn't it?
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: One
more example.
A beautiful landscape
photograph of
Queenstown that I took.
I think it's pretty great.
Let's see what Google can do.
Once again, tonal enhancement.
Doesn't need any skin
softening here.
Structure.
A little bit around the edges.
Darken the edges.
Look at the original and
what Google did.
Amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: All you have to
do is upload your images and
we will apply all of this for
you on all of your photographs
while still giving
you control.
This is an actual picture or an
actual shot of the product
itself that's rolling
out this afternoon.
If you mouse over any photograph
that's yours, we'll
show you that enhanced icon.
And when Matt clicks on that
enhanced icon, we'll go back
to the original.
And if you let go, you'll
see the enhancement.
And if you want, you can click
under the More menu, and you
can always turn this on or off,
either globally or on an
individual photograph.
So we think this is amazing,
and it's going to save you
lots of time.
Let's continue on.
We've talked about backup.
We've talked about enhancing,
highlighting your photos and
enhancing your photos.
Now let's talk about awesome.
Auto awesome creates a
new image from one
that did not exist.
Let me give you an example.
We have lots of these.
We recognize that you've taken
several pictures in burst mode
or taken around the same
time together.
We will automatically gift to
you in your album something
that looks like this.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: Here's
another example.
Maybe you've taken lots
of shots of children.
They're never looking
at the same time.
Go back to your album.
You'll see a gift for you.
You'll have another one of these
auto awesome motions.
By the way, over the past two
weeks in a dark launch state,
we've gone through all the
albums you've hosted on Google
and gifted all of
these to you.
You'll see them turned
on this afternoon.
These are five--
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: We're introducing
five auto awesome
effects today.
You saw a demonstration
of motion.
Let me briefly talk
about the others.
If we recognize that you have
multiple portraits together of
people, we will automatically
create a collage.
HDR is self explanatory.
We'll do that for you.
If we see multiple pictures of
the same people in burst moder
where they're not all smiling,
we will find where they're
smiling and we will construct
a new image
with all of them smiling.
It's amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: And,
finally, a pano.
So if you've taken an image, we
recognize it's at the same
spot, we'll stitch them together
beautifully and put
that in your album for free.
OK, so to summarize, today we've
shown you a new, modern,
multicolumn stream, a stream
that's about design and depth
so you can explore your
interests on Google+.
We've shown you a new Hangouts
application, one that's about
conversations that lasts with
the people you love.
And, finally, we've shown you
a new photos experience and
shown you what can happen when
Google is your darkroom.
Taken collectively, we
think we just put
the Google into Google+.
And we've finally allowed
technology to get out of the
way and allow you to do what you
do best, live, learn, and,
yes, even love.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: Now we'd like to
talk about what was possibly
your first Google
love, Search.
Join me in welcoming Ahmit
Singhal to the stage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIT SINGHAL: Yes.
It's a provocative
title, indeed,
especially coming from Google.
But I believe with
good reason.
Search is dramatically changing
right before our eyes.
And in the next 15 minutes,
I want to show you
how and in fact why.
But before we dive in, let me
just tell you why I'm so
excited to be here.
I grew up in small
town India in the
foothills of the Himalayas.
[CHEERING]
AMIT SINGHAL: Thank you.
And, yes, that's me
when I was three.
Very cute.
Indeed, my friends asked
me too, what happened?
Growing up, like many of you,
I was hooked on Star Trek.
I would watch endless episodes
of Star Trek, captivated by
the future technology
it showed.
I mean, a computer you could
talk to and it will answer
everything you ask it?
I dreamt of building that
computer one day.
And little did I know that I
would grow up to become the
person responsible for building
my dream for the
entire world.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT SINGHAL: Now, at Google
we are building three
experiences that are making huge
advances towards building
that dream.
The search of future will need
to answer, converse, and
anticipate.
And today we have announcements
across all these areas.
So let's start answers.
And let me show you what we
have been up to recently.
Last year, when we launched the
Knowledge Graph, it was a
huge advance in search
technology.
Knowledge Graph enabled Google
to move beyond keywords and
understand real wold entities,
unique people, places, and
things, and the relationships
between them.
Knowledge graph allowed us to
answer questions we couldn't
have answered before like what
are the movies by J.J Abrams?
Or what's the release date of
one of the most anticipated
movies of the season?
Now, we have been continuously
improving the Knowledge Graph.
With over 570 million entities
and growing, the graph becomes
more and more powerful
each day.
And today I am happy to announce
that very soon you
will start getting important
statistics powered by the
Knowledge Graph.
Now you can already find answers
to questions like
what's the population
of India.
However, starting today, we will
be anticipating your next
question, which may very well
be, how does it compare to the
population of other countries?
And not only will we give you
the answer alongside the trend
line, we will show you all that
in comparison to China
and the United States, the two
countries who are most often
compared to India
population wise.
Now, we have launched Knowledge
Graph in English and
eight other languages.
And today we are
adding Polish--
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT SINGHAL: Yes, my friends.
Turkish, simplified Chinese, and
traditional Chinese as new
languages for the
Knowledge Graph.
And while we are incredibly
excited about our progress
here, we're just getting
started.
And we know we can do a whole
lot better because sometimes
the answer you're looking for
is that song or that video
that your friend may have sent
you or it's your upcoming
flight or restaurant
reservation.
And you should be able to find
those answers from your own
world without having to dig and
sift through your email,
your documents, and
your calendar.
You should simply be able to ask
Google for your upcoming
flight or your trip plans,
even your restaurant
reservations or the package
that's about to arrive, and
even, of course, your
vacation photos.
Now, people who have opted in
to over Gmail search field
trial are already enjoying
this powerful experience.
However, something that is as
important as giving you the
answers and giving them to you
in the most natural way
possible is so that you can
pretty much ask Google like
you would ask a friend and not
by having to type keywords
into a search box.
This is why we have been working
hard on technologies
like voice recognition
and natural language
understanding.
Now, we have already launched
conversational search on
Android and on iOS platform.
You can tape the mic, ask Google
your question, and you
can get a spoken
response back.
And today, for the first time,
I'm happy to announce that all
this goodness of conversational
search will be
coming to all your desktops and
laptops through Chrome.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT SINGHAL: While you can
already use the microphone in
Chrome to search, we will be
bringing conversational search
and hot wording, a new
interface, or as I call it, no
interface so that you
don't even have to
click the mic to search.
You can sit back, relax,
say OK, Google--
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT SINGHAL: Ask your question
and have Google speak
back the answer.
So we talked about the power of
building these new powerful
experiences to answer your
questions and letting them ask
you in the most natural
way possible.
However, we think that another
essential experience is our
ability to anticipate and
suggest to you the right thing
at the right time even before
you ask for them.
Here, of course, I'm talking
about Google Now.
Google Now was launched
for Android last year.
And within a short amount of
time, it has become a must
have for its users.
Recently we launched Google
Now for iPhones and iPads
through the Google Search app,
and users are loving it.
It's getting better and
better by the day.
And the more you use
it, the more useful
it becomes for you.
And today we are happy to
announce that very soon you
will be able to set reminders
for yourself in Google Now and
they will show up at the right
place at the right time
whenever you need them.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT SINGHAL: In addition, we're
also launching public
transit commute time cards
and more cards for music,
television, TV shows,
and video games you
are interested in.
Now, we are confident that all
this momentum in Google Now
will make Google even more
useful as an assistive tool.
And we are very excited
about it.
But what we are really excited
about is how all these
experiences are coming
together to
make your life easy.
And the best way to understand
this is to
actually see them in action.
I'd now like to invite Johanna
Wright on the stage to show
you how all these experiences
are coming together in a
beautiful way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Thank
you, Amit.
I'm so excited to be here to
bring to life what Amit was
talking about.
Let's start with a scenario
that might happen in my
family, planning a day trip
to Santa Cruz with
my husband and kids.
I'm going to walk over
to the computer here.
And what you see here
is a Chrome browser
in full screen mode.
And Amit was talking
about hot wording.
Now, this is really hot.
We just took it off the
press this morning.
And I've actually never tried
hot wording in a room with so
much ambient noise.
So no hands.
OK, Google.
Show me things to do
in Santa Cruz.
FEMALE VOICE: Here are popular
attractions in Santa Cruz.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: What you see
here is coming from our
Knowledge Graph.
The Knowledge Graph knows the
Santa Cruz is a place and that
this list of places are
related to Santa Cruz.
I like the Natural Bridges
State Beach.
It's a nice place to relax
with my family.
But I kind of like something
more active.
What about the boardwalk?
OK, Google.
Show me pictures of the
Santa Cruz Boardwalk.
FEMALE VOICE: Here you go, some
pictures related to the
Santa Cruz Boardwalk.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Nice.
I love a wooden roller
coaster.
So does my husband.
It'd be nice to see if
our kids like it too.
The only question is will
the drive be too long?
OK, Google.
How far is it from here?
FEMALE VOICE: The drive from
your location to Santa Cruz
Beach Boardwalk is 73.9 miles.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE VOICE: That was
my favorite search.
And you know why?
It's because I barely
said anything.
It, here, well, somehow Google
knew that it was the Santa
Cruz Beach Boardwalk and
here was right here.
Now, the final thing that I'm
going to need to prepare is
where to eat.
My kids love seafood.
My daughter actually
loves muscles.
And it's pretty funny
to watch a
four-year-old eating muscles.
So why don't we try and find
a seafood restaurant?
OK, Google.
Show me seafood restaurants
in Santa Cruz.
FEMALE VOICE: Here are
addresses for seafood
restaurants near Santa Cruz.
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Now, I've heard
of this one, Johnny
Harborside.
I can click, look at the
details, and even go ahead and
make reservations right here.
So there you have it.
This is the latest voice
experience coming to Chrome
and Chrome OS.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Now let's
fast forward to my
trip to Santa Cruz.
Here I am enjoying
the beautiful
weather with my kids.
We're going on the
kiddie rides.
But you know what I'm
thinking about.
I'm think about how I can get
back to the Giant Dipper, that
old wooden roller coaster.
I don't know if my kids are
tall enough to ride it.
So we can walk over and check.
Or wouldn't it be more
convenient to just ask Google?
How tall do you have to be
to ride the Giant Dipper?
FEMALE VOICE: You must be at
least four feet, three inches
tall to ride Giant Dipper.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Nice.
Looks like my son can go on.
My daughter's too short so my
husband's going to have to
wait this one out.
So the next thing I'm going to
have to check is will I have
enough time to get to the Giant
Dipper and get back in
time for my reservation?
Now, Google Now anticipates
my information needs.
So when I swipe up into Google
Now, I see the reservation
right here.
It's at 2:00 PM and it's
only five minutes away.
So now I know I can make
it over to the
roller coaster in time.
And when I come back, I can
click on this Navigate link
and get turn by turn directions
right to the
restaurant.
So now let's fast
forward again.
I've ridden the roller
coaster.
I'm in the restaurant.
We're eating our muscles.
And my husband and my
conversation turns to an
upcoming business trip I have
to New York this week.
Usually on Wednesdays I take
my daughter to school.
But I'm not sure if this
Wednesday I'm going to have
enough time to get her to school
and then make it to the
airport to get my flight.
I don't quite remember
when my flight is.
So wouldn't it be great
to just ask Google?
When does my flight leave?
FEMALE VOICE: Delta Airlines
flight 1940 from SFO to JFK
leaves at 11:30 AM on May 22.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE VOICE: For those of you
participating in our search
field trial, this
will work today.
Now, the last time I was
in New York, I was
there with my family.
I wasn't there on business.
I was there with my family to
take them to see the sites.
I saw some old friends.
I had them meet my kids.
And my friend Katie asked me
to be sure to give her call
the next time I'm in town, be
sure that we can get together.
So before I forget, why don't
I get in touch with Katie?
Send an email to Katie.
I'll be in town on Thursday and
was wondering if you're
available for dinner.
OK, sent.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Now, Katie's
a bit forgetful.
So I want to make sure to
give her a call right
when I get to town.
Remind me to call Katie
next Wednesday.
What you see here is our
latest voice action,
reminders, that are launching
in Google Now today.
Reminders work on times,
dates, and locations,
including home and work.
Now, when I set this reminder
Google Now will remind me at
just the right moment.
Fast forward again.
Fly to New York.
I get out of my plane.
I go to get my taxi.
In the past what I would be
doing is rifling through my
backpack for the reservation so
that I could tell the taxi
driver where my hotel was.
But Google Now has just
the right information
just when I need it.
So I can swipe in, see my
reservation at the W. I scroll
down, I see my reminder
to call Katie.
So I've talked to
the taxi driver.
I've talked to my
friend Katie.
I'm just sitting back.
I'm so excited to be
back in New York.
I'm remembering the trip I had
last year when I took my kids
around, when they met
my friend Katie.
I'd love to show Katie the
pictures from this last trip.
Now, for my final demo, wouldn't
it be great if I
could just ask Google?
Show me my pictures from
New York last year.
Oh, and those are my pictures
from New York.
And there's Katie reading
a book to my kids.
These are the building blocks
and the experiences Amit was
talking about.
I hope you are starting to see
how it's all coming together.
With that, let's welcome
Amit back on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT SINGHAL: Thank
you, Johanna.
I'm incredibly proud of the
search experience that we are
building and tremendously
excited to bring it to
hundreds of millions of people
around the world on the
devices they rely
on every day.
It's important to remember,
though, this experience is
rapidly developing.
And it will take some time
before it becomes the
predominant search experience.
There are several complex and
unsolved scientific problems
that we will have to solve
before we get there.
But our investment and
commitment to getting there
sooner rather than
later is immense.
The announcements today are
a really good sign of the
progress we have made.
With more features in the
Knowledge Graph and more
languages, conversational voice
search and hot wording
coming to Chrome on desktops
and laptops, and new Now
functionality including
reminders and various other
cards, Search is really
becoming a beautiful
ubiquitous experience that
intelligently answers your
questions and assists
you throughout the
day across all screens.
The idea of building such a
powerful means of getting
knowledge to the world is what
inspires us every day.
With the simple touch of a
mike, from the Queen of
England to the most humble
farmer in Africa, from the
developer who just joined the
Glass Explorer program to that
the mother in a rural village
in India who just got her
first basic smartphone, everyone
can easily access all
of humanity's information and
get what they need to improve
their and their family's
lives.
That, my friends, is the power
of the new search experience
that we are building
at Google.
And it will change how you and
I experience this beautiful
journey that we call life.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT SINGHAL: And so we have
talked about the future of
search and how it's changing
right before our eyes.
And we know that a perfect map
of the word is foundational to
delivering exactly what you
want, when you want it, and
where you want it.
So I'd like to turn it over to
Brian McClendon to talk about
the future of Google Maps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN MCCLENDON: Thank
you very much.
Hi.
I'm Brian McClendon and I lead
the Maps team here at Google.
Google Maps help you navigate
from place to place.
But it also helps you explore
and discover the
world around you.
Today we're going to talk about
the future of Google
Maps and where it's going.
But to talk about the future,
I need to talk a little bit
about the past.
Back in 2005 Maps was
a problematic
experience on the internet.
It was very slow, 10 to 20
seconds fora a map, multiple
boxes you had to type
things into.
Google Maps came up with the
idea of pre rendering the map
tiles, providing that single
search box, and making a
smooth, fluid experience.
And we launched.
And many people were very
excited about it.
But Europeans had a
bit of an issue.
And they sent this
screen shot.
We had launched with only
part of the world.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN MCCLENDON: And it shows
the data is very important.
We worked incredibly hard.
And by 2008 we had licensed
data and had turn by turn
directions in 22 countries.
But we discovered that keeping
data up to date was very hard.
We created a project called
Ground Truth.
Ground Truth is taking
authoritative data sources,
combining with all of the
process and algorithms at
Google, and making the best data
set we can possibly make.
Recently we launched two more
countries, Thailand and
Indonesia, bringing it to a
total of 43 countries overall
with the Ground Truth data.
But this doesn't cover
the whole world.
In many cases, countries
didn't have good maps.
We created a tool called
map maker.
Map maker allows users to
contribute their data and make
the best maps they can.
And in some cases, those maps
are now the best maps that
country has anywhere.
And that's helped us cover 199
countries around the world.
But there's one country
that was missing.
We had some of it
in map maker.
But just very recently
we published North
Korea, making 200.
Now, you can take a
look at what North
Korea looked like before.
We just had this river
and the city name.
But adding all of the detail
for Google, actually having
people tell us the POI's, the
places, the parks, the
neighborhoods, the street, gives
it so much more depth.
And there's another thing you
see on this map that was
really important to us.
Geocoded photos changed the
experience of everything.
They allow you to dip into a
place and really get a sense
of the place exactly.
And those Geocoded photos
inspired us.
And in 2007 we launched a
product called Street View
which actually created
these big panoramas.
And we launched it in seven
cities in the United States.
But those seven cities
weren't enough.
Recently we launched two more
countries, Hungary and Lesotho.
And we now have 50 countries
around the world covered with
Street View imagery.
We've driven 5 million miles
with these cars.
But we haven't just taken
Street View on the road.
We've taken it on trains
up the Swiss Alps.
We've taken it down the
Amazon on a boat.
And even added beautiful imagery
from the Great Barrier
Reef and other places
around the ocean.
And as you can see here, this
is an incredibly immersive
experience.
So being able to go here, unless
you're a snorkeler or
scuba diver, you'll never
visit this place.
But you can really get a taste
of how the different places
look and preview the
place overall.
This was the imagination that
created Google Earth in the
first place.
Imagery is very important
to us.
And we've been working with
satellite imagery and aerial
imagery for a long time.
But in 2012 we started
generating new data from our
existing aerial imagery.
Combining oblique images, many
different photographs from
around a building, we're
actually able to generate 3D
geometry of large,
urban cores.
And we're now covering far more
places with 3D buildings
than we ever had before.
This idea of generating data
from other data is fundamental
to what Google does.
We have so many different
sources of it that there are
also so many different kinds
of areas you can have.
We have the base maps.
We have Street View drivers with
GPS tracks of their cars.
We have images from Street View,
Satellite, aerial, those
3D buildings I talked about,
and also terrain
data that we generated.
Each one of them is good
but can be improved in
combination.
And this combination, it's
called bundle adjusting.
And it's incredibly important
to improving the quality of
Maps overall.
You know, one of the best
examples of this is our local
business data.
Locating local businesses
precisely is
actually pretty hard.
But using Street View,
computer vision, and
algorithms we now have over 40
million precise geocodes
locating these businesses around
the world, making ours
the most comprehensive data set
of precisely located local
businesses.
So this data is at the basis of
everything that Google does
with its products.
But it's also at the basis of
everything that you do.
In 2005 Google Maps
API launched.
But in the last year we've had
30% year over year growth.
And today, I'd like to announce
we have over one
million websites using Google
Maps in their site and
improving their site.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN MCCLENDON: These sites are
visited by over a billion
people every week and actually
get more use than Google Maps
does on Google products alone.
So Google Maps API is incredibly
important to us.
And it's thanks to people like
you who've added their Google
Maps to the power of
their application.
Now, obviously applications
are important to you.
And you heard about Hugo
introducing the various mobile
APIs for Android.
And they have really improved
things with user location and
the Android SDK for Maps V2.
We also have Google
Maps SDK for iOS.
And being able to bring Google
Maps 3D camera motion and
fluid motion into your
applications, I think, has
changed a lot of the
applications around.
And the uptake has
been incredible.
I'd like to quickly introduce
the 17 sessions that we're
going to have in the Google
Maps track over the next
couple of days and highlight
one thing in particular.
There's a product called Google
Maps Engine that you
may have heard of, uploading
your data into the cloud.
If you can do that, you can
serve your data to everybody
with the same performance and
quality and integrate it with
the Google Maps experience.
And with the Google Maps API,
you can actually have your
applications read and write
that data set and really
change how things work.
But now I'd like to introduce
Daniel Graf, who is going to
talk about the next generation
of Google Maps for mobile.
Daniel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL GRAF: Thank you, Brian.
Hi, everyone.
I know when it comes to mobile
phones, everyone in here is
probably here for Android.
But as most of you probably
heard last December, we
launched Google Maps
on the iPhone.
It has been a tremendous
success.
The feedback has been
very positive.
People called it sleek,
simple, beautiful.
And let's not forget,
accurate.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL GRAF: So if you're an
iPhone user, you don't have it
on your phone yet, go
to the app store.
Download it today.
Brian talked a lot about the
power of Google Maps data.
He mentioned we're going beyond
just directions and
navigation.
Maps are also about exploring
and discovering places.
And no where is that
more critical
than on a mobile phone.
Today we're going to announce
and we're going to give you a
sneak preview of the next major
release from Google Maps
for mobile coming to enjoy
and, of course, iOS.
For that we're going
to take a little
stroll through San Francisco.
I'm going to start here
on my Nexus 4.
And, as you can see, when I
start this it's a brand new
design, a new look.
And actually we're at Moscone.
I can zoom in.
I can see all the beautiful 3D
buildings, which we also saw
in the Android demo before.
But for now, as I mentioned,
sometimes it's about what is
the right place to go.
So at the moment, let's say I'm
in the mood for Burmese
food and here in
San Francisco.
So I'm just going to search
for Burmese food.
And when you look at the
results, the first result we
get is Burma SuperStar
has a 4.0
rating, over 1,000 reviews.
Well, I want to find out more.
I actually see my friend,
Salahuddin.
He rated it five stars.
I trust his taste.
So I want to look
a little more.
I just swipe down.
I have different imagery
I can look at.
Of course, once you go there,
you can rate and review.
You can upload photos.
And as some of you, here
I have different
reviews I can see.
And some of you noticed
here, there's a rating
scale of 4.0 there.
So today we're going to announce
a new five point
rating scale across all Google
Maps products, so if you
search for a restaurant on
google.com or if you use Maps
on the desktop or on
a mobile phone.
Now I want to go to a
different use case.
And it's actually quite
a common one.
Now, how often have you
searched for pizza?
That's what we're going to do.
And we're going to do it this
time in the Mission District.
And let's see where we are.
Let's see what results
we're getting here.
And no surprise, we're getting
a lot of results.
And with this new UI,
it's very easy to
browse through it.
I can just swipe to
different results.
I can bring up the details
and look at is this a
good place to go.
But something caught
my eye here.
It's the Zagat badge.
What does that mean?
And before we looked
at user reviews
and my friends reviews.
But sometimes you want
to have a trusted
opinion from an expert.
We integrated a brand new
Zagat experience.
And, as you know, Zagat is one
of the most trusted brands on
opinions about restaurants
and places to go.
Here you see little cart.
And you see the pizzeria Delfina
is actually on a list
called restaurants worth the
wait in San Francisco.
I can also get all the details,
such as the editorial
review from Zagat and
the Zagat scores.
So sometimes it's important to
get a trusted expert to tell
you, hey, this is a
place you can go.
Now it has been quite a long
morning, an exciting morning.
But I'm going go back to where
we are right now around
Moscone and downtown here
in San Francisco.
And what I'm going to look
for is I'm in the
mood for some coffee.
So I'm going to search
for coffee.
And let's see what the
results are here.
And, for example, well, first
result, surprise, surprise.
There's a lot of Starbucks
in town.
Has a high rating.
And something else caught
my eye here, an offer.
Let's have a look at it.
And actually we have integrated
here a brand new
offers experience with great
deals from some of the world's
best brands.
In this example, this
is Starbucks.
And as we see, they're
introducing a new drink,
Starbucks Refreshers
this afternoon.
Half price off.
Please don't run there.
I'm giving you a preview here.
And if we go in there,
I can get the
details about the offer.
And then I can save it
for later as well.
So we see here the
offer about it.
I use it later.
And then I can go this afternoon
if I want to.
We have many launch partners
beyond Starbucks.
And there's many more to come.
This is the new offers
experience in
Google Maps for mobile.
So now I want to talk a little
bit about directions.
And a lot of you are using
public transport.
I know that when I look
at our numbers.
We have currently over a million
transit stops in the
whole world which we cover.
And for those who are using
cars or ride around with
bicycles, 50 billion kilometers
of turn by turn
directions.
Imagine, 15 billion
kilometers.
Today we're going to announce
several new key features to
make your navigation experience
even better.
For example, we have a revamped
incident experience.
We're adding live coverage
of incidents from
all around the world.
So in traffic view, for example,
you can see in real
time incident alerts.
You can just tap on it to see
details and then you know
what's going on.
Even cooler, another feature
is dynamic rerouting.
Let's say you're driving along
your route and something
happens ahead of you.
The conditions worsen.
Google gives you an early
warning and it tells you, hey,
there's a better
route to take.
So this was the next generation
of Google Maps for
smartphones.
And--
thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL GRAF: As we all know,
mobile today is not just about
smartphones.
Should we go a little bigger?
Screen size?
So I'm very happy to announce
today that we have a brand new
fully dedicated tablet
Maps experience.
And we're going to have
a little look here.
So we're still here
in San Francisco.
I'm going to scroll around
a little bit.
And actually we are
here downtown.
Here's something pretty cool.
And, by the way, all the
features you have seen on the
smartphone and on the tablet,
they work vice
versa on both platforms.
Here we're at Macy's.
We have indoors.
We have tens of thousands of
places in the world where you
can see into the buildings and
see what stores are there,
what you can find out
there, what's
going on in those buildings.
But sometimes you don't
really know what
you're in the mood for.
You're like entertain
me, show me.
What can I discover
in San Francisco?
I'm visiting here.
So you're not typing
in a search query.
All you do is-- and this
is a new experience.
You say let's explore.
And it's a beautiful explore
experience where you can say,
I'm in a mood to eat something,
to drink, to shop.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL GRAF: It's a little
early to sleep right now.
So I would say, let's play.
Let's get entertained.
And when I go through this, I
can go to museums, to public
parks, and--
well, let's take one you
probably heard before, the
Golden Gate Bridge.
Very high rating, 4.6.
As you get all the details here
and just at the touch of
a button, you want to see
how it looks like there.
You have the Street
View experience.
And, of course, it's very easy
to go there afterwards.
So this is a new way to explore
and discover your
surroundings.
There you have it.
So these were just a few of the
new features for Google
Maps for mobile.
It's a brand new experience.
And as I mentioned, we emphasize
a lot on discovery,
exploration, better navigation,
and a beautiful
new design.
We are truly excited about
this new product.
It's coming to your Android
devices and your iOS devices,
smartphones, and tablets
this summer.
It's pretty cool, right?
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL GRAF: Thanks.
But where are we going to go
next with Google Maps?
As Brian mentioned earlier on,
Google Maps launched in 2005.
We currently have over a billion
users every month
using our products.
And as you all know,
Google Maps has
defined modern mapping.
And we're about to reinvent
it again.
And for that I want to introduce
Berni and Jonah.
And they're going to tell you
a little bit more about the
future of Google Maps.
Berni, Jonah.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: Remember
the first time
you used Google Maps.
And now imagine that
same feeling again.
We have been working on
something that we believe
that's just that.
We looked at we have today
and we saw there's
three things missing.
Number one, you and me and
everybody else, we look at the
exact same map.
Wouldn't it be awesome if you
could build billions of maps,
one for every user?
And not only that, a map that
adapts to what you do, a map
built for you.
And number two, Google has all
this imagery, from satellite
to streets, indoors, and
even under water.
Wouldn't it be cool if you could
bring this all together
into one experience that would
be fun and easy to explore?
And number three, what if you
could make everything simpler
and more powerful by coming
up with whole new ways to
interact with the map
itself, making
that map-to-user interface.
With these three principles and
our great data foundation,
we went ahead and rebuilt Google
Maps on the ground up.
Jonah, show us how it looks.
JONAH JONES: This is the
new Google Maps.
[APPLAUSE]
JONAH JONES: Focusing the design
and the interactions on
the map had made everything
simpler and a
real pleasure to use.
The map is rich and
beautiful with
vibrant colors and textures.
BERNI SEEFELD: So this is a
computer running Chrome.
And we're using the latest open
standards like WebGL to
make the experience really
smooth since snappy.
These are vector maps
in a browser.
So let me tell you
a little story.
I just moved here about
a year ago.
This is a nice neighborhood.
And it was an exciting time as
I got to explore a new area.
And I love exploring.
And so one of the first things
I did was search for
restaurants.
And this is our new search
experience, no
more just ten pins.
All the results are labeled
directly on the map.
This makes exploring really
fast and easy.
And the top results, they come
with a useful description that
gives you a flavor of the
place so you can make
decisions very quickly.
No need for cross referencing
Everything is right
there on the map.
The map is the user interface.
Now, of course, there's this
other way how you can find
restaurants.
You can ask your friends.
And now you can do
that directly in
the new Google Maps.
We added a filter.
And now you see those search
results are the sushi places
that my friends have reviewed,
like Kiji here that my friend
Stephanie likes.
And these are our new cards.
They summarize everything that
is important about this place.
But earlier I was talking
about imagery.
And you see those
three photos.
And I love this part.
Let's take a closer look.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: We just flew into
our new immersive imagery
experience.
And it actually looks
like a great place.
I might go there tonight.
Let's head back out.
Clear the search.
So earlier I was saying this
map is built for you.
Let me show you how
that works.
So I've been living in this
area for about a year now.
And I've done many,
many searches.
I've reviewed places, starred
places, and I
made great new friends.
And my map got better
and better.
The places you see on this map,
they are my landmarks.
Like Frances here, that's one of
the first places I went to.
It's a great restaurant.
I love it and I keep
going back.
So it's very important to me.
And just the other day someone
told me about a bike shop and
said it's right next
to Frances.
And I knew exactly
where it is.
It is a landmark for me and
that's why it's on my map.
But it's a fairly small place.
So it might not be
on Jonah's map.
It might not be on your map.
But it's a landmark for me,
and so it's on my map.
And when you are logged in,
you get your map and we'll
highlight everything that
is important to you.
Now, it's not just about
all the places
that I already know.
A good friend of mine is in town
for I/O. And I thought we
could try a new restaurant.
My map is going to help
me with just that.
See these places here, they
are recommendations.
Like Bar Tartine shows
up because
it's similar to Frances.
And I looked like Frances so
it's a recommendation for me.
And Foreign Cinema shows
up because my
friend Anita likes it.
So these two look like
great options.
And this is how Google Maps
helps you discover new places
without even having to search.
So this is how we can build a
map for you using the same
data as Google Now so it will
get better and better the more
you use it.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: So that's
how we build a
map for every person.
Now let me show you how we build
a map for every place.
So next weekend some friends
of mine from Italy are in
town, and they have children.
So I thought we could go
to the Randall Museum.
It's near my home, and it's
really great for kids.
But it's a little bit
tricky to get to.
See, this little road here that
leads up to the museum,
it's not even labeled.
And that makes perfect sense.
It's a very small unimportant
road.
But it's important for
the Randall Museum.
So watch what happens
when we click on it?
Now the street is labeled and
all the other streets that
lead to this place are
highlighted as well.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: Let's
have another look.
Before, a regular map.
And after the roads are
highlighted and labeled.
This map makes it so much easier
to understand how to
get to this place.
So we can build a unique
map for every
place on every click.
Isn't that amazing?
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: But I know my
friend's kids and they will
definitely want to
explore more.
Now that's going to be really
easy because now all the
landmarks you see on
the map are related
to the Randall Museum.
And so they're all about
kids and museums.
You can see the Cartoon
Art Museum.
You can see the Walt
Disney Museum.
And when we click on that, we
get a whole new map with new
places to explore.
So we can click on the
Exploratorium.
And when we click on
Exploratorium, another map appears.
So we can keep going
and going.
This is a great way to
explore new places.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: It's
really east, just
clicking and clicking.
So it's simple and powerful.
The map is the user interface.
So now let's see how
we can get there.
So we could click here
on directions.
But for the most common case
there's an even simpler way.
See, my home is right
there on the map.
And it says a 60 minute drive.
So if I want to get directions
from my home, I can
just click on that.
And this is our new directions
experience.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: A great new
thing is that we directly
compare driving with public
transit on the map.
And that's going to be really
useful because this weekend we
won't have a car.
And we wanted to make public
transit much, much smarter.
Before, we showed you the
next three departures.
But now we are going to look
at every departure, every
second, for the entire
next week and
summarize that for you.
So you can see here that you
can take any of these lines
and they run every
three minutes.
So that makes taking public
transit so much easier.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: And if you want
more details, you can use our
new schedule viewer.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: So the
kids, they don't
want to walk too much.
So I'm looking for a trip that
has less walking and less
transfers even if it
takes a bit longer.
And, here, that looks
like a great one.
So this is the future of
getting directions.
[APPLAUSE]
JONAH JONES: Now, as Brian
talked about earlier, we've
collected tons of imagery.
And we made a real focus of the
design to make sure it's
easy and fun to explore.
BERNI SEEFELD: So my friends,
they're from Rome, and so they
insist that next time I
come and visit them.
So let's take a trip.
So this is a really nice
3D model of the
Saint Peter's Basilica.
But can we have a more
realistic view?
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: No plug-ins.
No downloads.
This is the Google
Earth experience
right here on a browser.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: And
that's not all.
You see those row of images
at the bottom.
These are other great
views of that area.
That makes it really
easy to explore.
And the beauty of this place
is really on the inside.
So let's go on a tour.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: This is a
3D photo tour that is
automatically generated from
user uploaded photos.
So it will only get
better and better.
So let's head back
to San Francisco.
So this is the Moscone center
from a skydiver's perspective.
But before the keynote started
I came up here on stage.
And with the camera up on my
Android phone, I took a photo
sphere and submitted
it to Google Maps.
And there it is.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: This is how you
guys look from up here.
So everybody can upload a photo
sphere and submit it to
Google Maps.
And so it's like user generated
street view.
And we also took a
photo sphere out
there on our geo pod.
And if you go there tomorrow
morning, we'll have
[INAUDIBLE].
And you can get the experience
you just
saw with elite motion.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: Let's
get back out.
So we jump back out.
And as we're zooming out and
we're leaving the Earth's
atmosphere, you can see
the whole world.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: And those clouds,
they're real time.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: But we
can go further.
[LAUGHTER]
BERNI SEEFELD: This is the Earth
traveling through space.
And you can see the stars
and the milky way
at the right position.
And as the sun sets behind
the earth, the
night lights come out.
And this is the future
of Google Maps.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN MCCLENDON: Berni, Jonah,
this is beautiful.
Now, when are we going
to get this?
How long is it going to take
for you to deliver?
BERNI SEEFELD: I don't think
these people want to wait.
BRIAN MCCLENDON: Do you
guys want to wait?
AUDIENCE: No.
BERNI SEEFELD: Well, you
can try this today.
This is the new Google Maps.
It has a preview
on the desktop.
So it's the perfect thing to
try to with your new Pixel.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNI SEEFELD: So when you pick
it up, check your inbox
and you will have an invite.
And everybody else, please go to
maps.google.com/preview and
sign up and we'll
send the first
invites tomorrow morning.
BRIAN MCCLENDON: Thank
you very much,
Berni, Jonah, and Daniel.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN MCCLENDON: So that is
the future of Google Maps,
data, APIs, a beautiful new
Google Maps for mobile coming
in the summer, and a desktop
Maps coming to
you in the room today.
So with that, I'd like to think
the geo team and all the
people who have worked on
this because it has
been incredibly hard.
But with that, the future
of Google Maps.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY PAGE: It was actually a
while ago I asked for the
picture of the earth at night.
And I'm really excited to
finally have gotten it.
Although, I'm still waiting,
actually, for a higher
resolution.
So let's give a big around of
applause to the Maps guys.
I think this is amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY PAGE: I'm really
excited to be here.
And first I want to start
with a story.
I was very, very lucky
growing up.
And I was thinking about this as
we were preparing for this
Google I/O.
My dad was really interested
in technology.
And I was just remembering he
actually drove me and my
family all the way across the
country to go to a robotics
conference.
And then we got there and he
thought it was so important
that his young son go to the
conference and one of the few
times I've seen him really argue
with someone to get in
someone underage successfully
into the conference.
And that was me.
And one of the themes I just
want to talk to you about is
how important it is for us, all
of the developers here in
the room and watching, to really
focus on technology and
get more people involved
in it.
And also thinking about my dad,
his degree, he was lucky
enough to get a degree in
communications sciences.
And you might ask
what the heck is
communication sciences?
That's what they called
computer science when
computers were a passing fad.
Sounds kind of funny
now, right?
But there was a time
when that was true.
And I think everyone today is
excited about technology.
We don't have to worry about
that so much anymore.
And I think that Android and
things like that are being
adopted much faster than
anything else in the past.
I look at the rate of adoption
of those things, on almost any
basis they are much,
much faster.
And it's incredible.
When I pull out my smartphone,
it's amazing what we have on
the smartphones.
We have almost every sensor
we've ever come up with.
I recently got a scale and it
measures air quality and
uploads it to the internet.
I'm sure those things will end
up in your smartphone.
That's amazing.
Your phone can talk to anyone
in the world almost anywhere
in the world.
And I was kind of remarking, I
was talking to my teams about
this, if you take out your phone
and hold it out, it's
almost as big as the TV or
screen you're looking at.
And it has the same resolution
as well.
And so if you're nearsighted,
which I see many of you out
there with glasses--
and even some Google
Glasses, thank you.
I think many of you
are near sighted.
And, you know, smartphone and a
big display are kind of the
same thing now, which is
amazing, absolutely amazing.
So I think we also have a lot
more devices that we use
interchangeably.
You know, we use tablets,
phones, laptops, and even the
Google Glass, all those
things we're using.
And that's why we put so much
focus on our platforms, on
Android and Chrome.
It's really important in helping
developers and Google
build great user experiences
across these different devices
to have these platforms.
And I'm tremendously excited
about all the innovation that
you're bringing to life.
Technology should do the hard
work so that people can get on
with doing the things that make
them happiest in life.
Take Search for example.
Perfect search engine, as Amit
mentioned, is the Star Trek
computer, right?
And understand exactly what you
meant and give you exactly
what you wanted.
And our Knowledge Graph, which
you saw, really brings that a
lot closer.
I think Google Now, which
Johanna just demonstrated,
gives you information without
even having to ask and it
understands the context of what
you talked about before
so you can use things
like pronouns.
It's amazing.
Flight times, your boarding
passes, directions, next
appointment, all
with no effort.
Think about a really smart
assistant doing all those
things for you so you don't
have to think about it.
You saw how easy some of
those experiences felt.
And we're just getting
started.
The opportunities we have
are tremendous.
You know, we haven't seen this
rate of change in computing
for a long time, probably
not since the
birth of personal computing.
But when I think about it, I
think we're all here because
we share a deep sense of
optimism about the potential
of technology to improve
people's lives and the world
as part of that.
And I'm amazed.
Every day I come to work the
list of things that needs to
be done is longer than
the day before.
And the opportunity
of those things is
bigger than it was before.
And because of that, I think
we, as Google, and as an
industry, all of you, are really
only at 1% of what's
possible and probably
even less than that.
And despite the faster change we
have in the industry, we're
still moving slow
relative to the
opportunities that we have.
And some of that I think is
due to the negativity.
You know, every story I read
about Google is kind of us
versus some other company
or some stupid thing.
And I just don't find that
very interesting.
We should be building
great things that
don't exist, right?
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY PAGE: You know,
being negative is
not how we make progress.
And most important things
are not zero sum.
There's a lot of opportunity
out there.
And we can use technology to
make really new and really
important things that make
people's lives better.
And if I think back to a long
time ago, a very long time
ago, all of humanity was
basically our farming or
hunting all the time.
And if you lived at that time
you probably hoped that you
could feed your family.
And, unfortunately, that's still
true for a lot of people
in the world.
But certainly for us we don't
worry about that.
And the reason for that
is technology.
We've improved how we
grow food and so on.
And the technology of that has
allowed people to focus on
other things if they choose.
By the way, I think being a
farmer's great if that's what
you want to do.
But it's not great if that's
what you have to do.
And that's what technology
lets us do is free up
ourselves to do more
different things.
And I'm sure that people in the
future will think we're
just as crazy as we think
everyone in the past was at
having to do things
like farming and
hunting all the time.
So to give an example
of this Sergey and I
talk a lot about cars.
You know, he's working on
automated cars now.
And imagine how self driving
cars will change our lives and
the landscape.
More green space, fewer
parking lots, greater
mobility, fewer accidents,
more freedom, fewer hours
wasted behind the
wheel of a car.
And the average American
probably spends almost 50
minutes, five, zero
minutes commuting.
Imagine if you got most of
that time back to use for
other things.
And, unfortunately, even in
other countries commute times
are still pretty large, not
quite as large as the US, but
still very significant.
Now to get there we need more
people, more people like you,
markets falling in love with
science and math at school,
more students graduating with
science and engineering
degrees, and more people
working on important
technological problems.
And it's why Google got involved
with the movie "The
Internship."
I'm not sure we entirely
had a choice.
But they were making a movie.
We decided it would be
good to get involved.
Lorraine's upfront.
She's really responsible
for that.
And I think the reason why we
got involved in that is that
computer science has a
marketing problem.
Where the nerdy curmudgeons.
I don't know about you,
but that's what I am.
And, well, in this movie the
guy who plays the head of
search, the Amit Singhal you
just saw, is by far the
coolest character
in the movie.
And we're really excited
about that.
So I think today we're still
just scratching the surface of
what's possible.
That's why I'm so excited.
Google's really working on the
platforms that support all of
your innovations.
I cannot wait to see
what comes next.
I got goosebumps as I was
watching some of the
presentations here.
And I really want to thank you
for all of your contributions.
So with that, I'm going to
do something kind of
unconventional and try to take
some questions, actually, from
all of you.
So I've got two microphones set
up towards the back here.
And don't be shy.
Line up and ask some
questions.
I'm sure some of you
have thought
of some good questions.
And we'll get started.
So thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY PAGE: All right, so
we got a few racing up.
Please line up so we can get
through them quickly.
And one question per
person, please.
We have 6,000 people.
I also want to call out the
one million people.
It's over one million people
watching this live on YouTube.
It's just unbelievable.
So let's thank them
for participating.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY PAGE: OK, yes, sir,
on the left here.
AUDIENCE: I'm Robert Scobler,
one of the first Glass-holes.
So thank you.
LARRY PAGE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
getting my glass.
LARRY PAGE: Robert, I really
didn't appreciate the shower
picture though.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Here at Google I/O
several contextual things
start coming out.
We start seeing an API that's
going to tell us whether we're
walking or running or whatnot.
Where are you going to take that
in the future now that we
have more sensors?
And are you going to talk about
the little sensor inside
the Google Glass that
watches our eye?
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, that's
a great question.
I mean, this is a big
area of focus.
I think you saw that in
the presentations.
I think really being able to get
computers out of the way
and really focused on what
people really need.
Mobile's been a great learning
experience, I think, for us
and for all of you.
You know, the smaller
screens, you can't
have all this clutter.
I think you saw on the new
Google Maps how we got all
sorts of stuff out of the way.
There's like 100 times less
things on the screen than
there was before.
And I think that's
going to happen
with all of your devices.
They're going to understand
the context.
Just before I came on stage,
I had to turn off all of my
phones so I'm not interrupting
all of you.
That's crazy.
That's not a very hard
thing to figure out.
So all that context that's in
your life, all these different
sensors are going to now pick
that up and just make your
life better.
And I think that we're, again,
only at the very, very early
stages of that.
This is very, very exciting.
All right, let's take
another question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Larry.
My name is Buckner.
I have the opportunity to work
at Mozilla on a lot of the web
technologies with you
guys here at Google.
And I saw a lot of the great web
technologies you had here
on display.
And I know people had this
question leading up to Google
I/O. But are we ever going to
see the web upleveled in
Android or subsume what is there
now to be the operating
system of mobile and
your platform?
LARRY PAGE: Sorry.
You're asking about the
future or the web?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Are we going to see it--
I mean, Android right
now runs on Java.
It's a native platform.
It's great in a lot of ways.
Are we going to see the web
and all the fantastic
technologies you showed
off here today be
the center of that?
LARRY PAGE: Well, I think we've
been really excited
about the web, obviously,
being birthed
from it as a company.
And I think that--
and we've really invested a
lot in the open standards
behind all that.
I've personally been quite sad
at the industry's behavior
around all these things.
If you just take something as
simple as instant messaging,
we've kind of had an offer
forever that we'll
interoperate on instant
messaging.
I think just this week Microsoft
took advantage of
that by interoperating with us
but not doing the reverse,
which is really sad, right?
And that's not the way
to make progress.
You need to actually have
interoperation, not just
people milking off one company
for their own benefit.
So I think Google has always
stood for that.
I've been sad that the industry
hasn't been able to
advance those things, I think,
generally because of a focus
on negativity and on
zero sum games.
So we try to be on the right
side of all those things.
But we also try to be practical
and look at what
other people are doing and not
just rely on our principles to
shoot ourselves in the foot and
our users in the process.
So I don't know how to deal
with all those things.
And I'm sad that the web is
probably not advancing as fast
as it should be.
We certainly struggle with
people like Microsoft.
We've had a great relationship
with Mozilla, I think, and
value that deeply.
I'd like to see more open
standards, more people getting
behind things that just work and
more companies involved in
those ecosystems.
I think that's why this
conference is so important.
But I wouldn't grade the
industry well in terms of
where we've gotten to.
In the very long term, I don't
think you should have to think
about as a developer am I
developing for this platform
or another or something
like that.
I think you should be able to
work at a much higher level.
In software you should run
everywhere easily.
And people like Mozilla should
be able to add meaningfully to
that and make platforms
and other things.
So that's how I would
think about.
AUDIENCE: Thank.
LARRY PAGE: It's a very,
very complex an
important question though.
Yes, yes.
Yes, mam.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
from Colombia.
And the only reason because I
didn't quite finish my law
studies was thanks to Google.
So I have dreamed in this
question many times.
And I would like to ask you how
Google will let us protect
our freedom of speech
through internet.
Thank you.
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, that's
a great question.
I mean, I think--
yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY PAGE: I mean, this is
part of the area where
business gets interesting,
right?
I think we at Google pretty
clearly have a strong desire
for freedom of speech for free
flow of information.
And one of the main things we do
is probably translate that
into practice in hundreds of
countries around the world and
make sure we're talking to
government leaders and making
sure we're helping
advance that.
And our chairman, Eric Schmidt,
has been kind of
traveling the world talking
about that.
And I really applaud those
efforts and thinking about.
So we're working very hard on
that, making sure we're
protecting your private
information, making sure that
we're ensuring computer
security, which is required to
make sure we're protecting your
freedom of speech and
your private information as part
of that and making sure
we're being as transparent as
we can about the requests we
get from government and
things like that.
So this is a big area
of focus for us.
And hopefully we can do a lot to
help the world and move it
along there.
It's a very difficult and
important issue also.
Yes, another great question.
AUDIENCE: I'm Ryan
from Provo, Utah.
Just recently Google Fiber
was announced for there.
And part of the marketing
campaign is 100 times the
speed, 100 times the
possibility.
What do you see as the
possibilities from that fast
of internet?
LARRY PAGE: Well, I think from
an engineering point of view
it's just kind of
a no brainer.
I mean, we got started building
data centers.
And one of the biggest
problems we have was
networking in the
data centers.
And so I guess has a computer
scientist I just view it as
kind of sad we have all these
computers out there and
they're connected to each other
through like a tiny,
tiny, tiny, tiny little pipe
that's super slow.
And so in a sense, all the
computers we have in the
world, most of them are
in people's houses.
Most of them can't be used
for anything useful.
So it's a obviously ways to
go from where we are now.
We don't really have software
that's designed to use those
things yet.
We know if we build that
capacity, we'll be able to use
those computers for all sorts
of interesting things.
And even basic things like the
bandwidth of your visual
system is pretty high
compared to the
bandwidth most people have.
And It think it's pretty clear
we want to deliver bits to
your eyes just as
a basic thing.
So I'm really excited about what
we'll be able to do and
what you'll all be able to do
as we get more people with
super high speed connections.
And probably gigabits or just
the beginning for that.
What we really need are low
latency connections that
operate at computer speed,
whatever that is that you have
inside your house.
So I'm really excited
about that.
So we're just getting started.
All right, in the middle now.
Yes.
The black shirt there.
AUDIENCE: I'm [INAUDIBLE]
from Vancouver.
We've seen Google move into
some physical real world
products like Google Fiber and
the autonomous self driving
cars and their renewable energy
cheaper than coal
initiatives.
Curious if you can elaborate
on further projects that
Google is planning to get into
regarding physical world type
initiatives.
LARRY PAGE: Yeah.
Well, my compatriot, Sergey
Brin, who last year arranged
the sky diving, but
this year did not,
I mean, he's focused--
Google X is focused on real sort
of atoms and not bits.
And part of why I feel there's
a lot of opportunity there.
And Sergey's having a great
time doing that.
And that's, I think,
a really, really
fascinating an amazing job.
I think that possibilities for
some of those things are
incredibly great.
If you look at technology
applied to transportation, it
hasn't really started yet.
We haven't really
done that out.
So I think automated cars are
just one thing you could do.
You can do many, many
other things.
So I think we're very excited
about that area.
And we also think it's a way
that the company can scale.
I think that to the extent
all of our products are
interrelated, we actually need
to do a fair amount of
management of those projects
to make sure you get a
seamless experience, both as a
user and a developer, that it
all makes sense.
When we do some of these other
kinds of things like automated
cars, they have a longer time
frame and less interaction.
And so I'd actually encourage
maybe more companies to try to
do things that are a little bit
outside their comfort zone
because I think it gets them
more scalability in what they
can get done.
And so I think we've been
surprised also even when we do
things that are kind of crazy
like automated cars, it turns
out you just saw the mapping
stuff we finished with.
The technology for doing mapping
and automated cars
turns out to be the same.
And so we have a bunch of great
engineers that have just
moved over from those efforts
and they did it naturally and
scalability.
And they're excited about it.
And so I'm really, really
excited about that too.
So every time we've done
something crazy--
Gmail, when we launched it, I
think we had 100 people in the
company when we launched
Gmail.
And people said, you're nuts.
You're a search company.
Why are you doing Gmail?
It's because we understand
things about data centers and
serving and storage that
we applied to email.
And that was a great
thing we did that.
And so I think almost every
time we've tried to do
something crazy we've made
progress, not all the times
but almost every time.
So we've become a bit
emboldened by that.
And the good news is too, no
matter how much money we try
to spend on automated cars or
Gmail in the early stages,
they end up being small,
small chunks.
So they don't really cause
a business issue either.
So I'm really excited
about that.
And I tried to talk about
that in my remarks.
That's why I say I think we're
at 1% of what's possible.
Yeah, another question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Hi, Larry.
It's Greg with the D-Sky 9.
We're developing apps
for Google Glass.
And I was really excited to see
all the new things that
Google is providing and also
realize that it kind of
trounced a bunch of existing
businesses.
I was wondering if you could
speak to what you feel are the
largest area of opportunities
for developing on Glass
outside of what Google will
provide naturally.
And a bonus question, what will
be the production run for
Glass for consumers.
LARRY PAGE: Well, I mean, I'd
have to ask Sergey that.
So I don't know what the
production numbers will be.
So I think we're more focused
on with Glass--
Glass is a new category.
It's quite different than
existing computing devices.
And so I think it's great that
we've started on it.
But I think our main
goal is to get
happy users using Glass.
And so we've put a bunch
out to developers.
I see a lot of people with
them in the audience.
We want to make sure we're
building experiences that
really make people happy.
And so the team has tried to
build the minimal set of
things, just for practical sake,
minimal set of things
that will provide a
great experience
and make happy users.
And then, you know, we can get
going and work on it for the
next 10 years.
And every successive one is
going to be better obviously.
So I think part of the answer
is we don't know.
I think the basic use
cases we have around
photography are amazing.
I love taking pictures my
kids with Glass and
movies and so on.
And I find that for
me that's enough.
I have the young kids.
For me that's enough reason
to have Glass just there.
I think if you didn't have young
kids you might not feel
exactly that way.
I'm not sure.
I have young kids,
so I can't tell.
Communications are also
pretty amazing.
Navigation is amazing.
Certainly if you're walking
if you're in
Manhattan or something.
Having Glass for navigation
is unbelievable.
I find it's really,
really nice.
And so navigations is amazing.
Some of the core experiences
we have are, I
think, pretty amazing.
Communications, phone
calls, SMS, voice.
You saw the things we're
doing around voice.
It's amazing to always have the
device there to do that.
So I think ultimately,
a lot of your
experiences can move to Glass.
And we're relying on all of you
to figure all that out.
We're trying to get the base
thing to make happy users so
we can get on with it.
AUDIENCE: We're aligned
with that.
Thank you.
LARRY PAGE: You're welcome.
Yes, over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
is Caleb Allen.
And I was wondering what advice
you would give to the
rising generation of
technologists?
What would help technology keep
moving at the pace it's
been moving at for the last
five or ten years?
And how would they do
that responsibly?
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, I mean,
that's a good question.
I think for me, I actually try
to use Google a lot and I
research things really deeply.
So, you know, before we get
something started, I try to
actually understand it.
And not just really understand
it, like, understand the crazy
people in the area.
And Google's great for that.
You can find the craziest person
in any given area.
And I think normally people
do not do that.
So I think you want to
think about the base
thing, whatever it is.
We've been, obviously, working
on smartphones a lot.
They're relatively
expensive now.
With Nexus 4 we tried to
improve that a bit.
But, you know, if you look at
the raw material costs of a
smartphone, I guess mostly glass
and silicon, tiny bit of
silicon, a little bit
of fibre glass.
I don't know, the raw materials
costs of it is
probably like $1 or something
like that.
I think Glass is $0.50 a pound
or something like that.
Certain metals are
$0.20 a pound.
Phones don't weigh
very much, right?
And silicon is very,
very cheap.
So, I think, when I see people
in industries who are making
things, I ask this question,
like, how far are you off the
raw materials cost?
And they never know the answer
to that question.
So I think kind of as an
engineer or as a technologist
trying to go to first principles
and say, what is
the real issue?
What is the real issue around
our power grids?
Or what's the real issue
around manufacturing or
whatever it is?
I think people usually don't
answer those questions.
And as a result, most of the
work that's done is very
incremental.
And because of that, we don't
make the progress we need to.
With that said, I mean,
it's very hard.
If you're going to make a
smartphone for a dollar, $1, I
mean, that's obviously almost
impossible to do.
But I think if you took a 50
year time frame or something
like that, if you took a longer
view, you'd probably
start to make the investments
you needed to.
And along the way you'd probably
figure out how to
make money.
So I'd just kind of encourage
non incremental thinking and a
real deep understanding of
whatever you're doing.
That's what I try to do.
Yeah, all the way over
on the right.
And then I'll make
another pass.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the future of Android.
So with Oracle taking control
of Java seven forward.
How does Google and advance
Android when one of the core
technical underpinnings is not
necessarily in its control?
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, I mean,
we've had a difficult
relationship with Oracle,
including having to appear in
court as a result of it.
Again, I think we'd like
to have a cooperative
relationship with them.
That hasn't seemed possible.
And I think, again, probably
money is more important to
them than having any kind
of collaboration
or things like that.
So I think that's been
very difficult.
I think we'll get
through that.
And I think, obviously,
Android's very, very important
to the Java ecosystem.
And so we'll get through
that just fine, just
not in an ideal way.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, another
question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Prishan.
I'm an Android developer
from India.
I'm a heave Google user.
And most of my opinion,
actually, I can trace back to
a Google search.
And as we saw today, it's
become more and more
personalized and predictive.
I kind of worry that it kind
of enforce my worldview and
kind of rule out the
possibility of some
serendipitous discovery of
other side, you know?
So any comment on that?
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, that's a
really great question.
People have a lot of
concern about that.
I'm totally not worried
about that at all.
And it sounds kind
of funny to say.
But that's totally under
your control and
our control, as Google.
So I think it's very important
to have a kind of widened
world view, to have education,
all those kind of things.
But the right solution to
that is not randomness.
So you can't really argue doing
a bad job of returning
whatever you wanted is the
right way to educate you.
It's just not.
It'd be better to return exactly
what you wanted when
you wanted and use that saved
time to have you read the news
or read textbooks or books or
other things that might be
more general.
And we can put that into
the algorithms.
So I guess in my very long term
worldview, 50 years from
now or something, hopefully
our software understands
deeply what your knowledgeable
about, what you're not, and
how to organize the world so
that the world can solve
important problems.
You know, people are starting
in the world not because we
don't have enough food.
It's because we're
not organized
to solve that problem.
And our computers aren't
helping us do that.
So I think if you think about
it that way, if you think
about we need to make computer
software and the internet that
helps people solve important
problems in the world, that
will cause, as a side effect,
for people to be educated
about the things they should
get educated about.
And that's not the
same as a demand.
I'm asking for a particular
thing I'm searching for.
Those are different modes.
So just kind of make sure we're
serving both modes and
that computers can
help you do that.
So I can not be more optimistic
about that.
I think computers and software
and things that you all write
and we all write are going to
help us solve those problems
for people rather than just
doing it at random.
All right, next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Larry.
I'm Asman from GBG
[INAUDIBLE].
It's great that Google has
developed a lot of new
technologies and allows
us to live in a better
way that we are today.
My question is not
about technology.
It's just a basic question for
the developers and the
countries that I came from
in the Far East.
We developers have been
developing, trying to develop
applications.
But one of the main issue for us
in many of the GDGs is that
we can't sell.
That's one part.
The other thing is that I have
been asked many times why
can't we buy paid apps?
That's my simple questions.
It's a great opportunity to
voice this one out to you.
And I hope things can be done
because I don't see any reason
why because people
want to buy.
And they can use their
credit cards.
Thank you very much.
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, I mean,
that scenario we've
had huge focus on.
So I think we've made
a lot of progress.
I think we'll make a
lot more progress.
But hopefully that's a very
temporary problem and we'll
get through that quickly.
But thanks for bringing it up.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Kevin
Nielson from New Jersey.
And I was intrigued about your
comment about the positivity
and the negativity.
And I'm very interested in
helping other people be
positive about technology,
as you are.
And I'm interested in what your
advice would be to help
us sort of reduce the negativity
and focus on
positive and focus on
changing the world.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
I think people naturally are
concerned about change.
And certainly not all
change is good.
And I do think the pace of
change in the world is
increasing.
Part of what I would think
about, I think, is I think
that we haven't adapted
mechanisms to deal with that.
And maybe some of our old
institutions, like the law and
so on, aren't keeping up with
the rate of change that we've
caused through technology.
If you look at different kinds
of laws we make or things like
that, they're very old.
I mean, the laws when we went
public were 50 years old.
The law can't be right if it's
50 years old, like, it's
before the internet.
That's a pretty major change
in how you might go public.
So I think maybe some of you
or maybe the million people
watching who love technology,
maybe more of us need to go
into other areas and help
those areas improve and
understand technology.
And I think that's not
happened at the
rate it needs to happen.
Yeah, thank you.
And the other thing in my mind
is we also haven't, maybe,
built mechanisms to allow
experimentation.
There's many, many exciting and
important things you could
do that you just can't do
because they're illegal or
they're not allowed
by regulation.
And that makes sense.
We don't want our world
to change too fast.
But maybe we should set aside
a small part of the world.
You know, I like going to
Burning Man, for example,
which I'm sure many of
you have been to.
[APPLAUSE].
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, a few
burners out there.
That's an environment
where people can try
out different things.
But not everybody has to go.
And I think that's a
great thing too.
I think as technologists we
should have some safe places
where we can try out some new
things and figure out what is
the effect on society, what's
the effect on people, without
having to deploy it kind of
into the normal world.
And people who like those kinds
of things can go there
and experience that.
And we don't have mechanisms
for that.
So those are the kind of things
I would think about.
I also think we need
to be honest.
And we don't always know
the impact of changes.
And we should be humble
about that.
I'm not sure getting up on stage
and saying everything is
amazing and so on is
the right thing.
Maybe we should launch things
in a little more humble way
and see what the effect
is an adapt as we go.
So those are kind
of my thoughts.
Yeah, way on the side here.
AUDIENCE: Larry, Ben Schacter,
Macquarie.
Health care impacts the society
in so many profound
ways and impacts the economy.
What are the strengths of Google
that you can bring to
help improve health care?
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, that's a
great, maybe, segue from the
previous question.
I think it's been difficult.
We had Google Health.
We didn't make much
progress on it.
And I think primarily we found
that all the issues were
regulatory.
It's very hard to get
technological leverage there.
So I was talking about we're
1% of where we can be.
That's by doing real amazing
technological things.
We found, certainly, in the
kinds of things we were
working on in health care, we
weren't able to move beyond
that due to all the constraints
that we were under.
And so I think we'll see amazing
things in health care.
But I think they'll be things
that have technological
leverage like DNA sequencing.
You know, we're clearly all
going to have that.
It's going to cost
$1 or whatever.
You're all going to have your
sequence and something amazing
will happen.
You know, I just disclosed
yesterday my voice issues.
I got so many great
emails from people
and thoughtful advice.
And I realized, you know, I had
the kind of notion, like,
this stuff should
be very private.
And at least in my
case, I feel I
should've done it sooner.
And I'm not sure that
that answer is not
true for most people.
So I ask, like, why are people
so focused on keeping your
medical history private?
And the answer is probably
insurance.
You're very worried
that you're going
to be denied insurance.
And that makes no sense.
And we should change the rules
around insurance so that they
have to insure people.
I mean, the whole point
of insurance is
that it insures everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY PAGE: So, again, maybe
we have a safe place where
people can go and live in a
world like that where they'd
make those kind of changes.
We can see if they work.
And then the world can learn
from that and move on.
But not everybody has to
participate in that because
I'm worried we're not making
some of the fundamental
changes we need to
make fast enough.
All right, maybe one or
two more questions.
We're going to run
out of time.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm John
Sarriugarte with Form &
reform, one of the Burning Man
artists you invited here
tonight for the after party.
Thank you.
LARRY PAGE: Oh, great,
AUDIENCE: I'm very inspired to
see that you've reached out to
the educational aspect.
I have a six-year-old.
Glad to see the Google's
moving that direction.
My question is about women in
the development community.
I'm looking around and I
don't see a lot here.
And I'd like to know
what we can do to
encourage women to be here.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: It's a simple
question.
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, I mean, we've
been super focused on
that forever.
Sergey and I, when we were
interviewing people, we spent
a lot of time interviewing women
for that reason, trying
to make sure our company didn't
end up all male, which
I think is a really,
really bad thing.
So I think ultimately the only
answer is we have to start
early and make sure we're
getting more young women and
girls really excited
about technology.
And I think if we do that,
there's no question we'll more
than double the rate of progress
that we have in the
technology world.
So we all need to do that.
We're trying to help with
that in any way we can.
And thank you for
the question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LARRY PAGE: Yeah.
All right, one more question.
AUDIENCE: Jefrey Siegal with
the University of Michigan.
While you had mentioned that
regulation is usually the
biggest problem trying to get
technology into health care,
I'm curious if you're going to
be doing anything with DNA
sequencing considering you
actually have all the
horsepower behind it, and also
image analysis, with things
like surgical slides and whatnot
because it seems like
that's a really big area that
we could get into to help
people as a whole.
LARRY PAGE: Yeah, I think those
are good questions.
I don't have anything to
announce at the time.
But we always look
at these areas.
We have felt it's a difficult
area for us to work in.
I think it's certainly
worth doing though.
All right, let's take one more.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm Josh Constine,
Techcrunch.
Could you discuss Google's
plan for bringing the
developing world online and what
you see as the social,
cultural, and political impacts
of democratized access
to the internet?
LARRY PAGE: That's a really
great question.
One of the things I always talk
about in the company when
I talk to the company is that
smartphones are going to
basically be amazing
in these places.
And so you don't quite have
smartphones, for example,
going into India or
Africa because
they're just too expensive.
The average cost of a phone in
India is very, very cheap, $50
or $100 or less.
I think more like $50.
And I think that we need to make
sure that the prices of
what we all are using quickly
make it down to those levels.
And I think they will.
That'll be the smartphone you
have today two or three years
from now will be in
Africa and India.
And that will be amazing because
I find I try to mostly
use smartphones now
just to make sure
I'm living that future.
I find I can get almost
everything I need done.
Unfortunately I don't get
to program that much.
But I can do most things I need
to do to run the company
on my phone.
So I think that's pretty amazing
to think that that can
go to three billion, four
billion, five billion, six
billion, seven billion plus in
not very long period of time.
And I think people are
underestimating how fast
that's going to happen.
I think it's clearly going to
happen very, very quickly.
And I'm really, really
excited about that.
We're trying to help that
happen quicker.
But I'm very excited
about that.
So thank you all so much for
spending so much time.
[APPLAUSE]